Hello and welcome to your second drink of Cafe Disco. Everyone, before you give this one a re-listen, I feel the need to address a fan mail flurry we got about this episode, specifically about how I am pronouncing something in the episode. Oh, yeah. I saw that in the mail. Yeah, you couldn't miss it. No. There was so much of it. So in this episode, there's a storyline that Jim and Pam are going to secretly elope in Ohio.
And I guess I said the name of the town wrong. It happens. repeatedly, though, like so many times. We've both done it. I guess I'm saying Youngstown, Ohio, and it really bugged people. One person said it was like, quote, nails on a chalkboard. So I guess everyone, brace yourself, and I apologize. Well, Jenna, you weren't the only person mispronouncing things. We got a letter from Matthew G. in Vermont, who said throughout the episode Cafe Disco,
Michael says espresso twice and espresso twice. Was espresso scripted as something Michael would say or was that accidental? Well, Matthew, I looked in the script and it was scripted as espresso, which means the times he said expresso were probably improvised. Which tracks, though. Tracks. It does. And then, lady, in rewatching the episode, I have a coffee mug catch that I didn't notice the first time at one minute and 47 seconds, Dwight is holding a mug, and I don't think I've ever seen this mug before.
What is it? It's not his usual mug? No, it's a Yankees mug. A Yankees mug. I know. A New York Yankees mug. I know. Why would he have that? I don't know.
That is odd. Good catch. I wonder if it's like something rain grabbed. I know, right? I know. Well, something else we didn't check on the first time we broke down this episode is if there were any real cafe discos out there in the world. And we've uncovered several shul-l-l-l-las and cereal shacks. But what about cafe discos? What did you find? Please tell me there are some. There are, but sort of. The closest match is a place literally called Cafe Disco. It's in Brisbane, Australia. It has coffee
and brunch from 7 a.m. to 2 p.m. with a Bangladesh-inspired menu. And they play music. but there is no dancing. Ah. So I also found a few places and they were doing more like disco cafes, which if you remember in the episode, Michael says this a no. Right. Kevin says like a disco cafe and Michael's like no, no, no, no. But I could not find anywhere where you drink coffee and dance.
That I could not find. So that is still open. And the thing I'm realizing with this rewatch is that Michael does not have the worst ideas for businesses. I mean, Michael Scott Paper Company wasn't great, but his others are pretty good. Cafe Disco sounds like a fun place. I know. Right?
And you know what? At our age, there is nothing I would love more than to go dancing at 1 p.m. You know what I mean? Yeah. That seems fun. With a latte. With a latte. All right, everyone.
Well, that's all we've got. Please enjoy your second drink of Cafe Disco. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office. together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies.
Hello, everybody. And Angela, can I get a good morning? Yeah, you can. Good morning, Jenna. Good morning, Sam. Good morning, Cassie. Good morning to you out there who's just starting your day and you're listening to us in your car. Or good evening to my night owls who are listening, Maybe by the fire. Maybe with a glass of line. I don't know. That was a beautiful picture that you just painted. Lady, guess what I did this morning?
What? Something new. I've never done it before. Exercise. No. But I'm so tickled by that. I took a contrast shower. I don't know what that is.
I didn't know what it was either. Is it a cold shower? It is an alternating hot and cold shower. Why would you do that? Okay, because it's supposed to have a bunch of health benefits, and you know me. I'll try anything. You could have gotten that shower at my grandparents' house in their guest bathroom. Does it just automatically alternate for you?
It used to. It was like, oh, wait, wait, who just started the dishwasher? Don't shower. Oh, that's true at our house. Don't do a load of laundry before you get in the shower. Or you could have a contrast shower. Well, here's what it's supposed to do. It's supposed to improve blood flow.
reduce systemic inflammation. It supports a connection between the brain and digestive system, but it's also just supposed to, like, energize you and kind of boost your immune system. I don't know. It's supposed to be beneficial, and it's sort of based on a thing that athletes do, you know, where they do a cold plunge and a hot shower and things. Right. Oh, my gosh, I wonder if Tom Brady does contrast showers.
Tom Brady does it all. That's what I mean. I'm telling you. He does it all. I should Google that. Do you think that's on the internet? How his water drinking is on the internet? Okay.
I bet it is. Okay. Well, listen, I did it this morning. You know what? Google Tom Brady's shower. Oh, no. Don't Google that. And see what you get.
Oh. Okay. Well, my husband's going to be like, why are you Googling? What is this search? They've given up on our search history. This is true. Wait, wait. Do you feel energized?
I kind of do. Okay. I do. I definitely felt energized when the freezing cold water hit my body after being in warm water. This would just be called grumpy shower in my house. I had to sort of sing it out during the cold part. Like when the cold water hit me, I was like, And it's cold. Yes, it's cold. You turned into like a ye oldy musical act. I did. And my kids were like, what is mom doing today? Anyway, there you go. That's what I did today this morning. Did you do any? Anything special or new or different, Ange? I did like 15 push-ups.
This morning? Yeah. Before we got here. Yeah. Do you remember John Krasinski used to do that? What? Yes, in the mornings. He would get to work, and before hair and makeup, he would do a bunch of push-ups and a bunch of sit-ups.
Oh, my God. To energize itself for the morning. You don't remember that? I was always so impressed, and I was inspired, and I thought, oh, I should do that. I tried it one morning, and I was like, I'm not doing that again. Well, I didn't do it either. I was lying. I was doing a joke, but geez, John. Wow.
I know. Should we get into this episode? Let's do it. This episode today is Cafe Disco. It is Season 5, Episode 27, written by Warren Lieberstein and Hallstead Sullivan, and directed by Randall Eynhorn. Would you like a summary? Yes. Concerned about the serious mood of his employees and just the general drab work environment at Dunder Miflin,
since Charles Minor left, Michael has decided to transform the former Michael Scott Paper Company into a cafe disco for socializing dancing and sipping espresso. Now, initially, nobody is interested, but it does slowly take off and ends up exceeding Michael's expectations. Meanwhile, Pam and Jim planned to secretly elope to Youngstown, Ohio, and Dwight tries to help Phyllis with an injury. It's a lot. That's a lot happening. That's a lot. And yet it's a pretty simple episode, really. Fast fact number one was a fan question from Becca D. What was the inspiration for this episode? We reached out to writers, Warren Lieberstein, and Halstead Sullivan. Yes, Warren and Halstead were a fantastic writing team. I knew them for a long time from our days at the groundlings. And some of you
guys listening to this no, and some don't, but Warren and I used to be married and we're good friends, and it was really fun to reminisce with both of them about this episode. Well, here's what he said about the inspiration for this episode, which I thought was amazing. He said that he and Halstead were pretty new writers at the time. They joined in this season, and they were tasked with coming up with an episode idea for what Michael Scott could do with this space that was formerly the Michael Scott Paper Company. He said that they were working in the writer's trailer with Brent Forrester, and the three of them were kind of pitching ideas like, oh, what if it's a cafe? What if it's a disco?
And they couldn't really decide. He said, for some reason, that day, Paul Lieberstein was also working in the writer's trailer. He was working out of B.J. Novak's office that was sort of off of this, like, communal area where... So he could hear them going back and forth. Yes, exactly. And Warren said that Paul just suddenly came out of the office and said, it's a cafe and disco. Michael Scott loves two things more than anything. Coffee and dancing. It's a cafe disco. And then he turned around, went back into BJ's office, and shut the door. And Warren said he
remembers Brent turning to them and saying, well, you heard him. And then the three of them just started outlining what is a cafe disco to Michael Scott. It feels very much like something your dad would do. You know, like he'd come out as you're arguing, be like, it's both. Just do it. Yes, exactly. Well, it is more interesting being both, isn't it? And it's more Michael Scott that it would be a strange hybrid of two things. Yes. Halsett had some really great stuff to share as well. And he told us that they want an NAACP Image Award for Best Writing for a Comedy Series for this episode. This episode is really popular. When I told people that we were breaking down Cafe Disco and when we were trading emails with Randy Cordray about this one, he was like, I I love this episode. I love the simplicity of it. It's just so beautiful. Yeah. Well, Halstead also said, Ang, guess what? There is a bakery in Oklahoma named Cafe Disco because they loved this episode so much. You can find them at cafe dash disco.com. He said, have you ever heard of that? Have any of the other episodes had a bakery named after them? No, we've just heard of shul-l-l-l-laws, but I think they existed before Michael's Shoe-L-L-L-Law.
That's true. Fast fact number two, we shot this episode in four days instead of five. How did we do that? Randy shared that because all the work was so contained in that one tiny location of the cafe disco, there weren't like a ton of different ways to cover it with the camera. So we were able to kind of get it pretty quickly. So they would basically, rather than having some giant master shot and all these close-ups, They just covered it.
He said it was kind of important that we do this in four days because this episode filmed the week right before Easter. And we were already meant to have Good Friday off for Easter weekend. And if we hadn't finished, we would have had to come back the Monday after Easter and pick up our fifth day. But that would have really thrown off our 100th episode Company Picnic, which was happening the next week. Which was a huge company move. That would have been... Yeah, that would have been really hard. Yeah.
That's what she said. So that leads me into Fast fact number three. While there were no locations for this episode, no expensive stunts or props, there was a lot of music. And to get the rights to all the music that was in this episode was a very complicated thing to pull off. Randy shared that there are two kinds of music rights. There are sync rights, which is where you're going to... going to play a song by the original artist, and that's all. You're just going to hear their song. Okay. But then there are master rights, and that's what you need if a character is going to sing or
hum a song. Sort of do their interpretation of the artist. And Randy said that they wanted us to be able to sing along or hum along as we were dancing, and so we had to get both sync and master rights to every single song. There was only one song. that appeared in the script. If you read the script, different scenes will say music is playing. Right. Aaron presses play, but it doesn't say what song comes out except for one time in the script. What did it say?
The one song that appears in the script is everybody dance now. And it's the song where Michael is playing it through the vents to get everybody to come down. And that song cost $40,000. Wow. And so Randy had our post-production supervisor, Jake Oest, reach out to Universal music, you know, because our show was made by NBC Universal. Right. And see if they could get a list of songs that we could license for either free or for not that much money. And then he gave that list to Warren and Hallstead.
And he said, what do you think? So Warren and Hallstead made a list of like their dream music list. Right. And then next to it, they would put a free alternative. And Randy sent this list over. It was really fascinating to look at. I'll just give one example. You know that opening scene when Michael's kind of dancing alone?
Yeah. Their first choice was Disturbia by Rihanna. Okay. Their free alternative, which appears in the show, is Car Wash. All right. For the most part, we had to go with their free alternative. I was going to say, I was going to say, I'm sure. The ultimate music budget for this episode was eight.
$85,200. Wow. Most of that money paid for everybody Dance Now and YMCA. But Randy said that another perk of not having that fifth shoot day was that they were able to allocate some of that shoot day's budget to music. That makes sense. And that's how we were able to pull it off.
“85,200美元。哇。这笔钱大部分都用来支付每个人都在跳的《Dance Now》和《YMCA》。但兰迪说，取消第五天拍摄的另一个好处是，他们能够把那一天拍摄预算的一部分分给音乐。这说得通。这就是我们能够成功办到的原因。”
But, I mean, that is all Randy's job. He's just like a spreadsheet and he has to move things around. Numbers, numbers, numbers. Yeah. And make it all happen. Well, my lady, those are. were some great fast facts. Thank you. Did you feel like they came from a person who had improved blood flow or maybe had a connection between their brain and digestive system? A hundred percent,
但我的意思是，这些全是兰迪的工作。他就像一个电子表格，不得不把东西挪来挪去。数字，数字，数字。是的。然后把这一切变成现实。好吧，女士，这些是一些很棒的快讯。谢谢你。你觉得它们来自一个血液循环得到改善或者大脑与消化系统之间有某种联系的人吗？百分之百，
I did. Thank you. I felt like that too. That's why I gave you the my lady and not just lady. Oh, yeah. Now we know. You got a special one. Well, I think we should take a break and when we get back, someone has won an art contest and it's not Pam. I know. Snark! G'day, I'm Justin Wolfers, host of the Platypus Economics podcast. If there's one thing I've learned from a career teaching economics, it's that your life is shaped by economic currents you'll never see.
我觉得是。谢谢你。我也是这么觉得的。这就是为什么我对你用的是“女士”而不是单纯的“小姐”。哦，是的。现在我们知道了。你遇到了一个特别的。好吧，我觉得我们应该休息一下，等我们回来时，有人赢得了一场艺术比赛，而那个人不是帕姆。我知道。冷嘲热讽！你好，我是贾斯廷·沃尔弗斯，《鸭嘴兽经济学》播客的主持人。如果说我从教授经济学的职业生涯中学到了什么，那就是你的人生是由那些你永远看不到的经济潮流塑造的。
A single price tag can explain things a thousand experts can't. People who understand economics, they make better decisions in their careers, their finances, their relationships and their communities, and I want that for you. Listen to and follow Platterpuss Economics. Available now wherever you get your podcasts. We are back. Should we get into this episode?
一个单一的价格标签可以解释一千个专家无法解释的事情。理解经济学的人，他们在自己的职业生涯、财务、人际关系和社区中做出更好的决定，我希望你也能如此。收听并关注《鸭嘴兽经济学》。现在在各大播客平台都可以收听。我们回来了。我们应该开始看这一集了吗？
Let's do it. How does it start? Well, we are in the Dundermifflin bullpen when Aaron, the new receptionist, squeals that she's won an art contest. Mm-hmm. Pam is not amused. Jenna was not amused. I had totally forgotten this cold open and I was like, oh my God. Dwight is.
我们开始吧。它是怎么开始的？嗯，我们在邓德米夫林的办公大区，新前台埃伦尖叫着说她赢得了一场艺术比赛。嗯哼。帕姆觉得一点也不好笑。珍娜觉得一点也不好笑。我完全忘了这个冷开场，当时我的反应是，哦，我的天哪。德怀特简直是
Such an ass in this cold open. He really is. And he's so tickled. He's so pleased with themselves. I do want to point out, while Pam is exchanging looks with Dwight in their desk pod, Pam's plant is on her desk as well as the little candy dispenser with jelly beans. Lady, we got an email from Audrey L who also noticed Pam's little candy dish. Audrey also mentioned that she really liked my hair in this scene.
在这个冷开场里太混蛋了。他真的是。而且他太自鸣得意了。他对自己太满意了。我确实想指出，当帕姆和德怀特在他们的办公桌隔间互相交换眼色时，帕姆的植物和那个装满果冻豆的小糖果机都在她的桌子上。女士，我们收到了一封来自奥黛丽·L的电子邮件，她也注意到了帕姆的小糖果盘。奥黛丽还提到她真的很喜欢我在这个场景里的头发。
She thought it was super cute. Did you notice my hair? Yes. It's one of those ponytails where you do ponytail. And then you, how do you explain it? Then you flip it through itself. Like a French. Oh my gosh. I 100% did my hair that way for one of my school dances. Like back in the day. Do people still do that hairstyle? I don't know if they still do the hairstyle, Jenna, but it's clear to me we were meant to be best friends because I once went to a high school dance with a side ponytail. And that was my choice. I styled. I started. it like that on purpose. Well, we often did ponytails when there was a standalone cold open. It was a way to differentiate Pam's look and hair from the actual episode. So something, if you feel like it, you could track it and see when Pam has ponytail. It's usually the cold open. We did a lot of that with Angela Martin, too. Just something different. It wasn't always a ponytail, but just something a little different for a cold open. I remember Angela, early in the series, you did a lot of buns.
她觉得超级可爱。你注意到我的头发了吗？注意到了。那是那种你先扎个马尾辫，然后你——怎么解释呢？——然后把它从中间翻过去的马尾辫。就像法式盘发一样。哦，天哪。我百分之百在我的一个学校舞会上把头发弄成那样。就像过去那样。人们现在还留那种发型吗？我不知道人们是不是还在留那种发型，珍娜，但很明显我们注定要成为好朋友，因为我曾经梳着侧马尾辫去参加过高中舞会。那是我的选择。我弄的。我故意弄成那样的。好吧，当有独立的冷开场时，我们经常扎马尾辫。这是一种将帕姆的外表和发型与实际剧集区分开来的方法。所以你可以追踪它，看看帕姆什么时候扎马尾辫。通常是冷开场。我们在安吉拉·马丁身上也做了很多这样的处理。只是有点不同。不总是马尾辫，但对于冷开场来说只是一点点不同。我记得安吉拉，在剧集刚开始时，你梳过很多发髻。
And then they started to give you headaches. Horrible headaches, guys. But then I remember you were like, you know what, I'll do a bun for the cold open. Yeah. You didn't want to like get rid of this hairstyle for Angela completely because it had been so established. But if you did a bun for a cold open, you only had to wear it for like four hours. Exactly. Our one full day, maybe.
然后它们开始让你头痛。可怕的头痛，伙计们。但后来我记得你说过，你知道吗，我会在冷开场时梳个发髻。是的。你不想彻底放弃安吉拉这种发型，因为它是如此深入人心。但如果你为冷开场梳个发髻，你只需要戴它大约四个小时。没错。我们完整工作的一天，也许吧。
Yes, but not five days. Not five days for 12 hours. I guess I just have one more question about this, which is, did you ever wear a bun to a school dance? No, no, but I did wear an updo the year we won the SAG award and I was super pregnant. I had an updo. I liked that on you. That looked nice. Thank you. Yeah. I was just so pregnant. I just was like, do I have to get in an evening gown? But no, no buns at high school dances. I don't think I did either. It's a bold choice. It is. In high school. True. Yeah. Well, this episode starts with my. Michael dancing by himself to car wash in what was Michael Scott Paper Company. All I could think about when I was watching him in there dancing was look at all the stuff Phil Shea had to get. Mm-hmm. He had to get an espresso maker.
是的，但不是五天。不是连续五天每天12小时。我想我关于这个只有一个更多的问题，那就是，你有没有梳过发髻去参加学校舞会？没有，没有，但在我们赢得演员工会奖的那一年，我确实梳了个盘发，而且我当时超级显怀。我梳了个盘发。我很喜欢你那样。那样看起来很好。谢谢你。是的。我当时肚子太大了。我只是在想，我一定要穿晚礼服吗？但没有，高中舞会上没有发髻。我想我也没有。这是一个大胆的选择。确实是。在高中时。真的。是的。好吧，这一集开始时，迈克尔独自一人在迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司里随着《洗车》的音乐跳舞。当我看着他在那里跳舞时，我能想到的全部事情就是看看菲尔·谢伊得准备多少东西。嗯哼。他得准备一台浓缩咖啡机。
Then the little espresso coffee cups and saucers, napkins, espresso coffee, the boombox, a lava lamp, a little desk lamp, a lay, all kinds of coffee accessories, an empty cheese puff container. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. A couple of chairs, and then eventually he'd have to get a tiny disco ball and some kind of the, I don't know, were they red chili pepper lights? Oh, yeah. Yeah. So Phil Shea, once again, simple episode, but he had all these little things he had to get. A lot of details.
然后是小浓缩咖啡杯和茶托、餐巾纸、浓缩咖啡、手提音响、熔岩灯、一个小台灯、一个花环，各种各样的咖啡配件，一个空的芝士球容器。嗯哼。嗯哼。几把椅子，然后最终他得弄到一个微型迪斯科球和某种——我不知道，那是红辣椒灯吗？哦，是的。是的。所以菲尔·谢伊，再次说明，很简单的一集，但他必须弄到所有这些小东西。有很多细节。
Yeah. Michael comes up to the office now, and he would like to have lunch with someone. Yeah, he really loved lunches at Michael Scott Paper Company. You know, I have to say, why did the camaraderie between Pam, Michael and Ryan have to end? I was loving it. Now it seems like, you know, their relationship is just kind of back where it started. I think that happens sometimes. I guess it does. They've sort of returned to their old roles, their routines. Well, then Michael has this kind of depressing talking head where he says,
是的，迈克尔现在来到办公室了，他想和某人一起吃午饭。是的，他真的很喜欢在迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司吃午饭。你知道，我不得不说，为什么帕姆、迈克尔和瑞安之间的情谊非得结束呢？我很喜欢那样。现在看起来，你知道的，他们的关系好像又回到了最初的原点。我想有时候确实会这样。我想是的。他们有点回到了他们旧的角色和日常中。好吧，然后迈克尔有了一个有点令人沮丧的面向镜头独白，他说，
at Dundra Mifflin, there is a very strict no lunch with the boss policy, and I don't know who instituted it. That broke my heart. I know. You know, Ryan says he can't have lunch with Michael. because he's doing five small meals a day. That was a really popular thing. Have you ever done that? I think that's just how I naturally eat.
在邓德米夫林，有一项非常严格的不允许和老板一起吃午饭的政策，我不知道是谁制定了这个政策。这让我心碎。我知道。你知道，瑞安说他不能和迈克尔一起吃午饭，因为他一天要吃五顿小餐。那是一个非常受欢迎的做法。你曾经那样做过吗？我觉得这只是我自然的饮食方式。
I thought of you when he said that. That is not how I naturally eat. I just sort of snack all day. Here's what I need to get through a day. I need three full meals. I also need a snack and I'm going to need a dessert. I forget to eat until about noon and then I'm crazy hungry. And then...
他说这话时我想到了你。那不是我自然的饮食方式。我只是整天吃点零食。以下是我度过一天所需要的。我需要三顿正餐。我还需要一份零食，我还需要一份甜点。我直到中午左右才想起来吃东西，然后我就饿疯了。然后……
I don't understand forgetting to eat. I wake up and the first thing I think of is when am I eating? It's like constantly on my mind. I'm already thinking about the yogurt that I brought for our snack the next time we take a break on the podcast. I'm like so food centered. Well, no one wants to have lunch with Michael. They say they have a lot of work to do. Michael starts doing his robot. Pam has to take the battery out or he'll just keep going, I guess. During this scene at three minutes, three seconds, there is a shot of my outfit. I have to point it out. I noticed it. I'm wearing a gray cardigan, a gray blouse, gray skirt, and Jenna, I'm wearing gray tights. I am wearing something on my legs. I never wore anything on my legs. I don't know why in this episode, but I do. I wonder if it was really cold because we were
我不理解忘记吃东西。我醒来时想的第一件事就是我什么时候吃东西？这一直在我的脑子里。我已经在想着我为我们在播客中下一次休息时带来的酸奶了。我太关注食物了。好吧，没有人想和迈克尔一起吃午饭。他们说他们有很多工作要做。迈克尔开始跳他的机器人舞。帕姆不得不把电池拿出来，否则我想他会一直跳下去。在三分钟零三秒的这个场景中，有一个我服装的镜头。我必须把它指出来。我注意到了。我穿着一件灰色开衫、灰色衬衫、灰色半身裙，而且珍娜，我穿着灰色连裤袜。我腿上穿了东西。我从不在腿上穿任何东西。我不知道为什么这一集里我会穿，但我确实穿了。我想知道是不是真的很冷，因为我们
shooting this in what sounds like March, early April, if it was around Easter. And that is, cold in L.A. Mm-hmm. That's like our cold stretch. I know. I just got excited, guys, because I would never wear the panty hose they put in my trailer. I was anti-pani hose.
在听起来像是三月、四月初的时候拍摄这个，如果是在复活节前后的话。洛杉矶的天气很冷。嗯哼。那是我们的寒冷期。我知道。我刚才很兴奋，伙计们，因为我绝不会穿他们放在我的保姆车里的连裤袜。我是反连裤袜的。
Also, maybe did you notice my shoes? I'm going to bring them up later. I didn't. Okay. But you're going to make me wait. Yeah. Okay. At three minutes, 10 seconds,
还有，也许你注意到我的鞋子了吗？我稍后会提。我没有。好吧。但你要让我等着。好吧。在三分十秒时，
Aaron finds a map of Youngstown, Ohio in the printer. And she brings it to Dwight. and he says this is a map to the Superior Court, and the only reason to go there is if you've been charged with a crime or if you want to try to get a learner's permit at 14.5. But this scene starts with Aaron saying, Hi, guys, how you doing? And then Dwight is like,
埃伦在打印机里发现了一张俄亥俄州扬斯敦的地图。她把它拿给德怀特，他说这是一张通往高级法院的地图，去那里的唯一原因是你被指控犯罪，或者你想在14岁半时尝试获得初学者驾照。但这个场景开始于埃伦说，嗨，伙计们，你们好吗？然后德怀特说，
Aaron, how many times I have to tell you, it's not necessary for you to ask us how we are every time you interact with us. We got a fan question from Lloyd C. in Australia. Who said? I recall in a previous podcast, it was mentioned that Rain Wilson made a big announcement about not needing to ask how his weekend was at the start of each week. He said, just assume it was good. Is this bit at Rain's desk between Dwight and Aaron may be based on Rain's weekend question rule? I don't know, but I will tell you the minute I saw that,
埃伦，我得告诉你多少次，每次你和我们互动时，你都没必要问我们过得怎么样。我们收到了来自澳大利亚的粉丝劳埃德·C的一个问题。他说：我记得在之前的播客中，有人提到雷恩·威尔逊曾大肆宣布，不需要在每周开始时问他的周末过得怎么样。他说，直接假设它是好的就行了。德怀特和埃伦在雷恩桌子旁这段戏，是不是可能基于雷恩的周末问题规则？我不知道，但我可以告诉你，我看到它的那一分钟，
it was the first thing I thought of. Same. Same here. I was like, that just feels like, rain. Yes. Yes. We also had a fan catch from Samantha R who said that Dwight mentions one of the reasons you would go to the courthouse is to obtain a learner's permit at age 14 and a half instead of 15. However, you have to be 16 to obtain a learner's permit. This has always stood out to me. And then Hannah W. said, I'm from Ohio and the minimum age for a learner's permit is 15 and a half. Well, I had to know. Okay. Here's the deal. You must be 15 and a half to obtain a learner's permit to drive a car. However, you can get a learner's permit for a motorized bicycle at the age of 14. All right, that's next year for Isabelle and Jack. And I cannot imagine those two, my kids, with anything motorized. I don't want them on anything that moves faster than a bicycle. If you were in Youngstown, Ohio, they could get a learner's permit. my gosh. Dwight had a really funny deleted talking head here. Oh, I can't wait. I'm going to read it to you. It cracked me up. Very sarcastically, Dwight says,
它就是我脑子里的第一想法。我也是。我也是。我的反应是，这感觉太雷恩了。是的。是的。我们还收到了来自萨曼莎·R的粉丝抓包，她说德怀特提到去法院的原因之一是在14岁半而不是15岁时获得初学者驾照。然而，你必须满16岁才能获得初学者驾照。这总是让我觉得很突出。然后汉娜·W说，我来自俄亥俄州，获得初学者驾照的最低年龄是15岁半。好吧，我必须知道。好的。情况是这样的。你必须满15岁半才能获得驾驶汽车的初学者驾照。但是，你可以在14岁时获得机动自行车的初学者驾照。好吧，伊莎贝尔和杰克明年就到那个年龄了。我无法想象这两个人，我的孩子们，带着任何机动的东西。我不想让他们骑任何比自行车移动得更快的东西。如果你在俄亥俄州扬斯敦，他们可以获得初学者驾照。天哪。德怀特在这里有一段非常搞笑的被删掉的面向镜头独白。哦，我等不及了。我要读给你听。把我逗乐了。德怀特非常讽刺地说，
oh no, I love Ohio. Next time you're there, say hi to my cousin Amil, and then kick him in the groin area because he's a cheat and a ball hog. And if he's still married to Clarissa, kick her in the groin area too, because she's a heartbreaking tart and a ball hog. Oh my gosh. What were they playing? Do they play, like, basketball and Clarissa and Emile, like hog the ball? What is happening in Ohio? Dwight's family is a mystery and very complex. Who knew he had relatives in Ohio? And also, apparently from this talking head, if Dwight were in Ohio and saw Clarissa and
噢不，我爱俄亥俄州。下次你在那里时，代我向我的表弟埃米尔问好，然后踢他的腹股沟区域，因为他是个骗子和独占球权的家伙。如果他和克拉丽莎还没离婚，也踢她的腹股沟区域，因为她是个让人心碎的荡妇和独占球权的家伙。哦，天哪。他们在玩什么？他们是在打篮球之类的，然后克拉丽莎和埃米尔独占球吗？俄亥俄州到底发生了什么？德怀特的家族是个谜，而且非常复杂。谁知道他在俄亥俄州有亲戚呢？而且显然根据这段独白，如果德怀特在俄亥俄州看到克拉丽莎和
Amel, he would kick him in the groin area, both of them. Incidentally, I am currently reading a book about Akron, Ohio. Okay. It's by this amazing writer, this guy, David Giffles. He lives in Ohio, and he and his wife decided to put a lowball offer on this like broken down house mansion. Like literally when he describes it, there's like sunshine coming through this thing. It's like the money pit. A hundred percent the money pit. And the book is just a memoir of them fixing it up absolutely by themselves while they lived in it. I don't know. It's just this amazing book, and I'm loving it. I had thought of it for my dad, who's a big, like, DIY fixer person. Yeah. I gave it to him for his birthday, and he loved it.
埃米尔，他会踢他们的腹股沟区域，他们两个。顺便说一句，我目前正在读一本关于俄亥俄州阿克伦的书。好的。作者是一位了不起的作家，一个名叫大卫·吉弗斯的家伙。他住在俄亥俄州，他和他的妻子决定对一栋破旧的豪宅出一个低价。字面意思上，当他描述它时，阳光穿透了这个建筑。这就像是那个无底洞电影。百分之百的无底洞。这本书就是他们一边住在里面一边完全靠自己把它修缮好的回忆录。我不知道。这真的是一本极好的书，我很喜欢。我曾为我父亲考虑过这本书，他是一个狂热的、喜欢自己动手修缮的人。是的。我在他生日那天送给了他，他很喜欢。
So I like Ohio, at least through the eyes of this book, for sure. Are you and I going to get a fixer up or in Ohio? No, I bought a fixer up in L.A. and spent a year. And so maybe that's also why I am relating to it. But, yeah. Same. You and I love a home project, man. I got a fixer up or two.
所以我喜欢俄亥俄州，至少通过这本书的视角，肯定是这样的。你和我打算去俄亥俄州买一套需要修缮的房子吗？不，我在洛杉矶买了一套需要修缮的房子并花了一年时间。所以也许这也是我能对它感同身受的原因。但是，是的。我也是。你和我都很喜欢家居装修项目，伙计。我有一两套需要修缮的房子，
and I'm still fixing it up. Pam and Jim are going to have this talking head where they say there are other reasons to go to Ohio. And the reason they're going is because they're getting married and it's the closest place that they can get a marriage license without the three-day waiting period. This talking head is so cute. I mean, my gosh, we are so cutie pie in this. Jim and Pam at peak cuteness. Yes. They just feel like, you know, the wedding planning, it's getting really complicated.
而且我还在修缮它们。帕姆和吉姆将有一段面向镜头独白，他们在其中说去俄亥俄州还有其他原因。他们去那里的原因是他们要结婚了，那是可以获得结婚证且没有三天等待期的最近的地方。这段独白太可爱了。我是说，天哪，我们在这里面太可爱了。吉姆和帕姆达到了可爱的巅峰。是的。他们只是觉得，你知道的，婚礼筹备变得越来越复杂。
It's getting really expensive. And Jim said, at breakfast, I want to marry you today. So they're going to go for it. It's so sweet. It's very much young love to me. Yeah. Yeah. But I also remember in wedding planning, having that moment where you get overwhelmed.
变得越来越昂贵。吉姆说，在早餐时，我想今天就娶你。所以他们决定放手去试。太甜了。对我和来说非常像年轻的爱。是的。是的。但我也记得在筹备婚礼时，有过那种不知所措的时刻。
And you're like, why are we doing this? I know. So I could relate as well. I mean, Josh and I, we went to the courthouse in Santa Barbara a month before our wedding and we're like, just get married. Let's just take that off the plate, you know? Then I guess the wedding is more of a celebration. Exactly. You can separate those two moments.
然后你会想，我们为什么要这样做？我知道。所以我也能感同身受。我是说，乔许和我，我们在婚礼前一个月去了圣巴巴拉的法院，然后我们觉得，就直接结婚吧。让我们把那个从待办事项里划掉，你知道吗？然后我想婚礼就更像是一场庆祝活动了。没错。你可以把那两个时刻分开。
Yeah, we did that. I loved it. We had a fan catch about this bit of info about Youngston, Ohio as well. Carrie C. wrote in and said, I've lived in Youngston, Ohio all my life. I got married in Youngston, and you cannot get a marriage license the same day here. It takes 10 to 14 working days, but I do love the Youngston reference. You can get a same-day marriage license in Las Vegas.
是的，我们那样做了。我很喜欢。我们收到了关于俄亥俄州扬斯敦这条信息的粉丝抓包。凯莉·C写信说，我一生都住在俄亥俄州扬斯敦。我在扬斯敦结的婚，你不能在那里当场拿到结婚证。这需要10到14个工作日，但我确实很喜欢扬斯敦的梗。你可以在拉斯维加斯拿到当天就能生效的结婚证。
Well, Mary L wrote in to say that there is no waiting period, that it's true. And then Andrea V said, I did a little deep dive and there is no superior court in Youngston, Ohio. So a lot of mail about these Youngston Ohio details. Yes. So here I'm going to clear it up for everybody. Andrea is right. There is no superior court. Okay.
好吧，玛丽·L写信说没有等待期，这是真的。然后安德烈亚·V说，我做了一点深入研究，俄亥俄州扬斯敦根本没有高级法院。所以有关于这些俄亥俄州扬斯敦细节的大量邮件。是的。所以在这里我要为所有人澄清一下。安德烈亚是对的。没有高级法院。好的。
But there is the Youngston Municipal Court. Okay. And as far as marriage licenses go, I went to the city applications, frequently asked questions, and it says that while there is a Youngston Municipal Court, that's not where you go for your marriage license anyway. No. You need to apply for a marriage license at the Mahoning County Probate Court. And even if you're out of state, you can get a marriage license there as long as you have your wedding ceremony in Mahoning County. You need to be 18 years old. You're going to need your Social Security card, two forms of identification. You're going to have to state your place of birth, your parents' names, no blood test, and it costs $43 cash. $43. Cash? Cash.
但有扬斯敦市法院。好的。至于结婚证，我看了城市申请的常见问题解答，上面说虽然有扬斯敦市法院，但那并不是你办结婚证的地方。不对。你需要去马霍宁县遗嘱检验法院申请结婚证。而且即使你来自外州，只要你的婚礼仪式在马霍宁县举行，你就可以在那里获得结婚证。你需要满18岁。你需要你的社保卡，两份身份证明。你必须说明你的出生地、父母的名字，不需要验血，费用是43美元现金。43美元。现金？现金。
No, Venmo. Not PayPal. Nope. No. Cash only. Not in Mahoning. Nope. How long is your marriage license valid in Youngstown, Ohio? Are you asking me? The website asked. Oh. And answered. It is valid for 60 days. And here it is. There is no waiting period before you can use your marriage license in Mahoning County.
不是Venmo。不是PayPal。没有。只收现金。马霍宁县不收。没有。在俄亥俄州扬斯敦，你的结婚证有效期是多久？你是在问我吗？网站上问了。哦。并且回答了。它的有效期是60天。这里是：在马霍宁县，使用结婚证之前没有等待期。
There it is. There it is. Everything you ever needed to know about getting a marriage license in Ohio, specifically Mahoning County. Correct. During all of this Ohio conversation, Michael is on a dance break, guys. And Aaron is going to be a marriage. to bring him some messages. And he's like, no, no, no, no work here. They have espresso. They come upstairs.
就是这样。就是这样。关于在俄亥俄州特别是马霍宁县获取结婚证，你需要了解的一切。没错。在所有这些关于俄亥俄州的对话期间，迈克尔正在进行舞蹈休息，伙计们。埃伦要成为一个婚姻……去给他带一些消息。而他的反应是，不，不，不，这里没有工作。他们有浓缩咖啡。他们来到楼上，
And Michael decides to tell the group about the downstairs room. Yeah, he and Aaron entered. They both have their little espresso cups. And by the way, I just noticed that you say it the way I used to say it. Oh, I put an X in it. You say espresso. I know. It's espresso. But a lot of people say expresso. I know. And I think it's okay. I think we should let it go. It's espresso. Espresso. Espresso. We had a fan catch from Hannah C. Who says in this episode, Aaron drinks an espresso. But in season 9, episode 11, the office gets an espresso machine and Aaron says she's never had one before.
迈克尔决定向大家讲述楼下房间的事。是的，他和埃伦进去了。他们俩都拿着他们的小浓缩咖啡杯。顺便说一句，我刚注意到你的发音方式和我过去一样。哦，我里面发了一个X的音。你说的是“expresso”。我知道。是“espresso”。但很多人说“expresso”。我知道。我觉得没关系。我觉得我们应该顺其自然。是espresso。Espresso。Espresso。我们收到了来自汉娜·C的粉丝抓包，她说在本集中，埃伦喝了一杯浓缩咖啡。但在第9季第11集中，办公室弄到了一台浓缩咖啡机，埃伦说她以前从没喝过。
Oh, good catch. I thought that was good. Yeah. Michael's going to give a big speech now. He is. And I absolutely love this runner. To me, this is classic The Office bullpen back and forth where everyone is chiming in. where it really gets funny to me
哦，好抓包。我觉得这很好。是的。迈克尔现在要发表一个大演讲了。他是。我绝对喜欢这个连续笑话。对我来说，这是经典的《办公室》办公大区互动，每个人都在插话。真正让我觉得搞笑的地方
is when Dwight does his Jack Nicholson impression which I thought Rain did a really good job I thought so too and this takes us down this road where Meredith is like wait it's a haunted coffee house Michael's like no no Dwight's confusing you it's more of a disco and then Andy says a haunted disco
是当德怀特模仿杰克·尼克尔森时，我认为雷恩模仿得非常好。我也这么认为，这把我们带入了这样一个方向，梅雷迪思觉得等等，这是一个闹鬼的咖啡馆吗？迈克尔说不，不，德怀特把你搞糊涂了，这更像是一个迪斯科舞厅，然后安迪说是一个闹鬼的迪斯科舞厅
Michael's like with coffee but without the haunted and then Phyllis is like it's a combo dance house coffee bar and Michael says it's a daytime disco on the ground floor of an industrial office building. And Aaron goes, it's a cafe disco. Michael's like, exactly. And then Kevin says, so like a disco cafe? And Michael's like, no, not even close.
迈克就像喝了咖啡一样，不过没有那种受惊吓的样子，然后菲利斯就说，这是一个复合舞厅咖啡吧，迈克说，这是工业办公大楼底楼的一个白天迪斯科。阿伦说，是个咖啡迪斯科。迈克说，完全正确。然后凯文说，所以就像个迪斯科咖啡馆？迈克说，不，差得远呢。
These were my favorite kind of scenes to shoot. And immediately after this scene, there would have been a Stanley talking head, where he says this. How did I end up back in crazy town? And then immediately after that would have been, an Oscar talking head and Oscar said this, it still seems really confusing as a concept. That would be Oscar's like take on it. He's very practical and literal. Right. Like what is your business plan? This seems confusing. Then Michael tries to entice everyone to come. He offers them all
这些是我最喜欢拍的场景。在这个场景之后紧接着会是一个斯坦利面对镜头的独白，他在其中说了这样的话。我怎么又回到了疯人镇？紧接着那个镜头之后会是一个奥斯卡的面对镜头的独白，奥斯卡说了这样的话，作为概念来说，这看起来还是让人觉得很迷惑。那是奥斯卡对这件事的看法。他非常务实而且死板。对的。就像你的商业计划是什么？这看起来很令人迷惑。然后迈克试图吸引每个人都来。他向他们提供所有的
the espresso you can eat. Ooh, well done, Angela. Thank you. And this is when this awesome runner would have started that I'm calling Kevin's Bacon Runner. A Kevin Bacon. Bacon Runner. Kevin Bacon Runner. It's in deleted scenes. Kevin sees Lynn at the elevators and they have this exchange. Hi, Kevin. Hey, Lynn. Did you have bacon for breakfast? No. Because you smell like bacon. I didn't think I did. How's everything going? Tight. I'm going down the hall to this office to see Michael. There's three espressoes. I would invite you, but I remember that you just want to be friends.
你能吃得下的浓缩咖啡。哦，干得好，安吉拉。谢谢你。就在这个时候，这个精彩的插曲开始了，我把它叫做凯文的培根插曲。一个凯文·培根。培根插曲。凯文·培根插曲。它在被删减片段里。凯文在电梯旁看到了琳，他们有这样一段对话。嗨，凯文。嘿，琳。你早饭吃培根了吗？没有。因为你闻起来像培根。我觉得我没有。一切都好吗？紧凑。我正顺着走廊去这间办公室找迈克。有三杯浓缩咖啡。本来想邀请你的，但我记得你只想当朋友。
We can still... Are you sure that you didn't eat bacon? Yes. Whatever it is, I like it. Okay. So then he walks away and Lynn has a talking head. Did she eat bacon? You gotta hear it.
我们还可以……你确定你没吃培根吗？是的。不管是什么，我都喜欢。好吧。然后他走开了，琳有一个面对镜头的独白。她吃培根了吗？你得听听这个。
Yes, I had some bacon this morning. I just didn't think it was anyone. I didn't think it was anyone's business. But wait, it gets better. Kevin just can't get Lynn and the bacon smell off his mind. And he asks her out. I love the smell of bacon on a woman. Hey, Lynn, it's Kevin.
是的，我今天早上吃了一些培根。我只是觉得这不是什么。我没觉得这是谁的事。但是等等，还有更精彩的。凯文就是无法把琳和培根的香味从脑子里赶走。于是他约她出去。我喜欢女人身上培根的味道。嘿，琳，我是凯文。
I was thinking about going and getting a coffee at the cafe disco. I'm wondering if you want to go with. Wow. Yes. So later when you see them slow dancing and then when they have a on makeout, it all started with this bacon scene by the elevators. That was amazing. What a find. I know. I so enjoyed it. Well, when Michael is kind of describing his inspiration for this disco and how it's going to bring people together and it's going to make people happy and kind of break them out of their funk, I have to say that he is right on about disco in general. I was reading a bunch of. about disco and listening to disco music when I was prepping this episode.
我在想去咖啡迪斯科喝杯咖啡。我想知道你想不想一起去。哇。是的。所以后来当你看到他们跳慢舞，然后他们有一次法式热吻时，这一切都始于电梯旁的这个培根场景。太棒了。多么棒的发现。我知道。我太喜欢了。嗯，当迈克有点在描述他办这个迪斯科的灵感，以及它将如何把人们聚集在一起，它将如何让人们快乐并让他们摆脱沮丧时，我不得不说，他对迪斯科的整体看法完全正确。我当时读了很多关于迪斯科的书。在准备这一集时听了迪斯科音乐。
This is very you. I know. I like a theme. It is your sounds of Scranton. It really is. And here is what I found out. And I pulled a couple of quotes because I loved them. So disco in general is just a very inclusive and accepting culture.
这非常符合你的风格。我知道。我喜欢一个主题。这就是你的斯克兰顿之声。确实是的。这是我发现的。我挑了几句名言，因为我太喜欢它们了。所以总的来说，迪斯科是一种非常包容和接纳的文化。
It was very communal. It was more than just music. It really was a cultural movement. And there's this book called Turn the Beat Around by author Peter Shapiro, and he called disco, quote, the embodiment of the vision of peace that the 60s yearned for. An article in Timeline.com went on to say, Disco was created by black and Latino musicians in the early 70s and popularized by mostly gay DJs for a mostly gay crowd celebrating new freedoms earned by the gay rights movement. And finally, now Rogers, the guitarist for the hit disco band Sheik, said,
它非常有集体感。它不仅仅是音乐。它确实是一场文化运动。有一本书叫《把节拍转回来》，作者是彼得·夏皮罗，他把迪斯科称为，引述，20世纪60年代所渴望的和平愿景的化身。Timeline.com网站上的一篇文章接着写道，迪斯科是由黑人和拉丁裔音乐家在70年代初创造的，主要由同性恋DJ为主要是同性恋的人群普及，以庆祝同性恋权利运动赢得的新自由。最后，作为热门迪斯科乐队“时尚”吉他手的纳尔逊·罗杰斯说，
This was the world I wanted to live in where everybody was cool with everyone. That was because of the music. That was disco. I mean, I'm a kid of the 70s, you know. My mom and her friends were so excited because they got to go see Donna Summer in concert. The queen of disco. My mom said it was a phenomenal show. How cool that your mom got to see her perform live.
这就是我想要生活的世界，每个人对每个人都很酷。这是因为音乐。那是迪斯科。我是70年代的孩子，你知道的。我妈妈和她的朋友们非常兴奋，因为她们去看唐娜·萨默的演唱会了。迪斯科女王。我妈妈说这是一场非凡的演出。你妈妈能看到她现场表演真是太酷了。
I know. I would have loved to go on with you. my mom. I was too little because I love disco. But Angela Martin, of course, is not a fan of Michael pulling everyone off of work and taking them down to his disco cafe cafe disco. And you'll see that Kevin is there very messily making his espresso. And it's because he's waiting for Lynn. Had you seen all of that deleted runner, you would know he's hoping Lynn will show up. In fact, in the shooting draft, the scene is more extended. And Kevin tells Michael he's waiting for Lynn. Wow.
我知道。我真想跟你一起去。我妈妈。我太小了，因为我喜欢迪斯科。但是安吉拉·马丁当然不喜欢迈克把大家从工作岗位上拉下来，带到他的迪斯科咖啡馆、咖啡迪斯科。你会看到凯文在那里一团糟地冲泡他的浓缩咖啡。这是因为他在等琳。如果你看过所有那些被删减的插曲，你就会知道他希望琳会出现。事实上，在拍摄剧本中，这个场景更长。凯文告诉迈克他在等琳。哇。
Before Angela enters. And this scene when I enter, I could barely get through, Jenna. I think you can tell I'm breaking if you watch it, because whenever Steve is Michael offers Kevin the fake cookie in his hand, I literally, I start smiling when I talk because I'm having such a hard time not laughing. It's so absurd and wonderful. And a lot of that is Brian Baumgartner's performance. Yes.
在安吉拉进来之前。当我进到这个场景时，珍娜，我几乎快演不下去了。我想你能看出如果你看的话我在笑场，因为每当史蒂夫饰演的迈克把假饼干递到凯文手里时，我一说话就会笑，因为我太难忍住不笑了。这太荒谬了，太美妙了。这很大程度上归功于布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳的表演。是的。
His like immediate belief that there's a cookie in a hand that clearly didn't have. have a cookie one second ago. Yes. Well, the three of us improvised the whole last couplet of dialogue. No way. Yes. So in the script, I mean, the script was phenomenal. But as we started doing it, Steve, as Michael just kept messing with Kevin. He kept showing him the cookie, but then pulling it a little out of reach. So Kevin had to walk further into the room. And that was just stuff we were making up on the day. Well, in the script, it was just a little cleaner of an ending, right? It was a little simpler. It was like Michael said Kevin stay. Angela said Kevin come.
他那种立刻相信手里有一块饼干的反应，明明一秒钟前手里根本没有饼干。是的。我们三个人即兴发挥了整段对话的最后对白。不会吧。是的。所以剧本里，我的意思是剧本太棒了。但当我们开始拍的时候，史蒂夫饰演的迈克一直捉弄凯文。他一直向他展示饼干，但随后又把它拿得有点够不着。所以凯文不得不往房间里走得更深。这只是我们当天临时编出来的东西。在剧本里，结局要干净一点，对吧？要简单一点。就像迈克说凯文留下。安吉拉说凯文过来。
And then Michael's like Kevin cookie. And then Kevin's like, what? There's a cookie. And then I drag them away. We just had so much fun with this fake cookie. We just improvised this little couplet at the end where Kevin's like, wait, is there a cookie? And I'm like, no, for goodness sakes, Kevin, there's no cookie. There's no cookie.
然后迈克说凯文饼干。然后凯文说，什么？有饼干。然后我把他们拉开。我们对这块假饼干玩得太开心了。我们在最后即兴发挥了这么一小段对白，凯文说，等等，有饼干吗？我说，没有，看在老天的份上，凯文，没有饼干。没有饼干。
Come on. And I kind of like show him. I'm trying to pry Michael's hand. And Kevin's like, I wanted a cookie. And then I look back at Michael and I'm like, completely unacceptable. It was so fun. We had a blast. And somewhere out there, there's just footage of me laughing every time Kevin looks at Michael's hand and is like, what is there a cookie? It's so good. Well, now Michael is alone. He really wants people to come. So he is going to blast music through the vent. Yes. And people up in the bullpen can hear it. And everyone kind of starts, you know, moving and grooving a little bit. So much so that Phyllis decides, she, She's going to go. Yeah, she says to heck with it.
行了。我有点像展示给他看。我试图撬开迈克的手。凯文说，我想要饼干。然后我回头看着迈克，我说，完全不可接受。太有趣了。我们玩得很开心。在某个地方，有我每次看到迈克的手并说“什么，有饼干吗”时都在笑的镜头。太棒了。现在迈克独自一人了。他真的很想让人来。所以他要通过通风口放音乐。是的。楼上办公区的人能听到。大家开始，你知道的，稍微有点扭动和摇摆。以至于菲利斯决定，她，她要去了。是的，她豁出去了。
But first she's going to stop by Vance Refrigeration to invite Bob, where she runs into Bob's younger yet sort of look-alike secretary. This is how this character was described in the script. As Phyllis walks in, Bob's busty secretary, Jessica, is coming out of Bob's office and closing the door behind her. She wears a low-cut top. Phyllis looks her up and down. Oh, wow. So it doesn't mention that she's meant to sort of be this younger version of Phyllis. Because they dressed her just like Phyllis dresses.
但首先她要顺道去万斯冷冻公司邀请鲍勃，在那里她遇到了鲍勃年轻一点但有点像他的秘书。剧本中是这样描述这个角色的。当菲利斯走进来时，鲍勃波涛胸涌的秘书杰西卡正从鲍勃的办公室走出来，顺手关上身后的门。她穿着一件低胸上衣。菲利斯上下打量着她。哦，哇。所以并没有提到她应该有点像是年轻版的菲利斯。因为他们的穿着打扮和菲利斯一模一样。
I know. I know. And I felt like even like their little noses were similar and everything. Their hair styles. Yes. She's clearly like what Phyllis would think Bob would want a younger woman. Yes. Which I thought was such a great casting choice. The women who played Jessica was Alyssa Preston.
我知道。我知道。我觉得甚至连他们的小鼻子都很像之类的一切。他们的发型。是的。她很明显就像菲利斯认为鲍勃会想要的年轻女性。是的。我觉得这是一个非常棒的选角选择。饰演杰西卡的演员是阿莉莎·普雷斯顿。
And according to her IMDB, This job was her first television credit. Oh, she did so great. Do you remember your first television job? Oh, God, I do. What was it? What was it? Oh, my very first line on a television show was a TV show called Step by Step.
根据她的IMDB资料，这份工作是她的第一个电视署名作品。哦，她演得太棒了。你还记得你的第一份电视工作吗？哦，天哪，我记得。是什么？是什么？哦，我在一个名为《一步一步》的电视节目中的第一句台词是一个电视节目。
The big stars were Suzanne Summers and Patrick Duffy. Was it a three-camera show? It was a multi-camera show. In the episode, they think their daughter has run off to elope. And I was cast because I was the same height and same hair color as the young girl playing their daughter. Mm-hmm. And they burst in to this wedding chapel, like in Vegas or somewhere.
大明星是苏珊·萨姆森和帕特里克·达菲。那是三机位节目吗？那是一个多机位节目。在那集里，他们以为女儿离家出走去私奔了。我被选中是因为我和扮演他们女儿的小女孩身高一样，发色也一样。嗯哼。他们冲进这个婚礼小教堂，就像在拉斯维加斯或者别的什么地方。
They burst in, and I'm up there saying my vows. So Suzanne Summers whips me around at the altar. And she goes, you're not Dana. And I say, no, I'm Simone. And thanks for ruining the best day of my life. Wow. It's like crazy that I remember that. And I auditioned for it.
他们冲进来，我正站在那儿宣誓。所以苏珊·萨姆森在圣坛前猛地把我转过来。她说，你不是达纳。我说，不，我是西蒙妮。谢谢你毁了我一生中最美好的一天。哇。我居然还记得这个，真是疯狂。我去试镜了。
And it wasn't for like two months later that I shot it. And I said to the director that day, I said, how do you want me to do it? And he said, just like you did in the audition. I couldn't remember how I did it in the audition. Oh, no. And then when I did it, they were like, can you tone it down? Because I guess I was like, but thanks for ruining the best day of my life. Well, that's the worst.
而且过了大约两个月我才拍它。那天我对导演说，我说，你希望我怎么演？他说，就照你试镜时的那样演。我记不得我在试镜时是怎么演的了。哦，不。然后当我演的时候，他们说，你能收敛一点吗？因为我猜我当时像是，但是谢谢你毁了我一生中最美好的一天。好吧，那是糟糕透顶的。
When you have one or two lines on a show and there's no like entrance ramp to your performance. You just have to deliver this one line exactly right. And you're on this new set with new people and there's all this just adrenaline running through you. And Suzanne Summers, hi. I've watched her my whole childhood whips me around. And while I was waiting to do my scene after the director gave me that note in rehearsals, I literally was in the wings going, thanks for ruining the best day of my life. Thanks for ruining the best day of my life. Thank you for ruining the best day.
当你在一个节目中只有一两句台词，而且你的表演没有助跑阶段时。你必须把这句唯一的台词说得恰到好处。你身处一个有新人们的新布景中，你身上充满了肾上腺素。而苏珊·萨姆森，嗨。我从小看到大的偶像，猛地把我转过来。当我在排练中导演给了我那个笔记后等待拍我的戏时，我 literalmente 站在侧幕条后面说，谢谢你毁了我一生中最美好的一天。谢谢你毁了我一生中最美好的一天。谢谢你毁了我最美好的一天。
That's the other problem when you have one line. You way over-analyze it. Oh, so much. I was horrible. Well, Alyssa Preston was amazing. She was. Her first TV job. She has gone on to work steadily in television and film.
这就是你只有一句台词时的另一个问题。你会过度分析它。哦，太多了。我当时演得太糟了。嗯，阿莉莎·普雷斯顿太棒了。她确实很棒。她的第一份电视工作。她后来一直在电视和电影界稳步工作。
She was in Grey's Anatomy, Modern Family, Jane the Virgin, the movie Horrible Bosses 2. No Monk, no Law & Order. Comedy. Comedy gal. Back to the story at hand. Phyllis has decided to go down and start dancing with Michael while she waits for Bob to join her. Yeah, and she's really getting into it so much so she does kind of this pony move and throws out her back. That gasping sort of bleeped mother effort that she says is not in the shooting draft.
她参演过《实习医生格蕾》、《摩登家庭》、《处女情缘》、《老板难当2》。还有《神探阿蒙》、《法律与秩序》。喜剧。喜剧女孩。回到手头的故事。菲利斯决定下去和迈克一起跳舞，同时等鲍勃加入她。是的，她真的很投入，以至于她做了某种踢踏动作并闪了腰。她说的那个喘息式的、被消音的“妈的努力”并没有出现在拍摄剧本中。
Really? Yeah, it says that she lets out a yell, you know, but I think that they had fun with that on the day. Can I just say that Phyllis is very good at fake injury? I so believed it. I was worried for her. I know. I mean, she gets her, like, whole face to turn red and stuff. And, like, everything she does as a person with a back injury was so right on for me.
真的吗？是的，上面写着她发出一声大叫，你知道的，但我认为他们在拍摄当天玩得很开心。我能说菲利斯非常擅长假装受伤吗？我太相信了。我当时很为她担心。我知道。我的意思是，她让她的，整张脸都变红了之类的。而且，就像她作为一个背部受伤的人所做的一切对我来说都太对路了。
She's great at physical comedy. I've got a side story. What? I know we just had one. Uh-oh. I threw out my back once, just like Phyllis. And it was while I was talking to Christy Brinkley. What?
她很擅长肢体喜剧。我有一个插曲。什么？我知道我们刚刚讲了一个。哦，不。我曾经闪过一次腰，就像菲利斯一样。那是我在跟克里斯蒂·布林克利说话的时候。什么？
Yeah. Christy Brinkley. How do you throw out your back while talking? Phyllis was dancing. Well, I was backstage. I was doing this game show. And Christy Brinkley was in the waiting room. She was going to be a guest on the next version of the game show, you know, the next episode. Sure, sure. I was just so excited. I mean, to maybe meet Christy Brinkley. Did you run up or something? I threw my arms out in a gesture where I was like, hi, Christy Brinkley. And in throwing, just, Just gesturing my arms open, I threw out my back. It was like a pop. It felt like something popped in my back. But I was trying to hold it together because she smiled and she was talking with me. And I don't know if she could see the pain like washing over my eyes and my whole body. And like I said, you know, Phyllis gets all red. I felt hot. Like I felt that. And then it just seized up. Like I couldn't even move. They brought the men. in. On the game show. Yes. They gave me some ice and some Advil. And from there, I had to get loaded in a car to go to this movie in Canada with Ben Stiller and Mike White. It was my dream job. My dream job. I'm playing Ben Stiller's wife in a Mike White movie. And you couldn't move. I couldn't move. All because you wanted to show Christy Brinkley a big gesture.
对。克里斯蒂·布林克利。你聊天怎么能把腰闪了？菲利斯当时在跳舞。嗯，我在后台。我在录制这个游戏节目。克里斯蒂·布林克利在休息室里。她将成为该游戏节目下一期（你知道的，下一集）的嘉宾。当然，当然。我当时太激动了。我的意思是，能见到克里斯蒂·布林克利。你跑过去了吗或者别的？我张开双臂做出一个手势，好像在说，嗨，克里斯蒂·布林克利。就在抛出，只是，只是比划着张开双臂时，我把腰闪了。就像“啪”的一声。感觉背里有什么东西断了。但我试图保持镇定，因为她笑了，而且在跟我聊天。我不知道她是否能看到痛苦在我的眼睛和全身蔓延开来。就像我说的，你知道，菲利斯变得通红。我觉得很热。我有那种感觉。然后它就痉挛了。我甚至都动不了。他们把男人们带进来了。在游戏节目里。是的。他们给我一些冰块和一些阿司匹林。从那以后，我不得不被抬上一辆车，去加拿大拍这部由本·斯蒂勒和迈克·怀特主演的电影。这是我的梦想工作。我的梦想工作。我在迈克·怀特的电影里扮演本·斯蒂勒的妻子。而你却动不了。我动不了。就因为你想向克里斯蒂·布林克利展示一个大动作？
Hey! Yes. When I got to the airport, They had to have a wheelchair load me onto the plane. I mean, I really couldn't walk. When I got to Canada, they had a doctor meet me at my hotel. This is crazy. And the next day, it was a driving scene. My character was supposed to drive, and I couldn't do it. And I was mortified.
嘿！是的。当我到了机场，他们不得不让人用轮椅把我抬上飞机。我是说，我真的走不动了。当我到达加拿大时，他们让一名医生在我的酒店见我。这太疯狂了。第二天，是一场开车戏。我的角色本应开车，但我做不到。我感到羞愧难当。
I was mortified. Because, of course, when everybody was like, how did you throw out your back? And you were like, I just made a hugging gesture. Yeah. I just went, hey. And then I seemed like a loony tune. But anyway. You can throw out your back very easily.
我感到羞愧难当。因为，当然，当每个人都问，你是怎么闪到腰的？你会说，我只是做了一个拥抱的姿势。是的。我只是说了句，嘿。然后我看起来像个疯子。不管怎样。你很容易就会闪到腰。
You can. Just ask you. A lot of stories for me today. Okay. Is this what the shower has done to me? Yes. It has opened up my vault of stories. It has.
确实很容易。问问你就知道了。我今天有很多故事。好吧。这就是淋浴对我做的事情吗？是的。它打开了我的故事宝库。确实如此。
Well, I want you guys to notice while Phyllis is being lowered to the ground by Michael, that black pipe on the wall by the shower does not have any lights on it, but that will change. Oh, it's not lighted now, but it will be. That's right. Michael calls Dwight down to help him get Phyllis back up into the office. Or is it Philip? Is it? He gets a text.
嗯，我想让你们注意到，当菲利斯被迈克放倒在地上时，淋浴旁边墙上的那根黑管子上没有任何灯光，但这将会改变。哦，它现在没亮，但一会儿就会亮。没错。迈克把德怀特叫下来帮他把菲利斯弄回办公室。还是菲利普？是吗？他收到一条短信。
He goes, you said, you said something happened to Philip? And then he looks at Phyllis and goes, did Philip do this to you? They are hilarious, the two of them. Well, this is going to start a whole runner where Dwight is going to be tasked with taking care of Phyllis in the conference room. They're going to wheel her in there. He's going to shut all the curtains. Yeah. And then there's a huge commotion.
他说，你刚才说，你刚才说菲利普出了什么事？然后他看着菲利斯说，是菲利普对你做了这个吗？他们两个太搞笑了。嗯，这将引发一连串的事情，德怀特将负责在会议室照顾菲利斯。他们要把她推到那里去。他要拉上所有的窗帘。是的。然后会有一场巨大的骚动。
He comes out in just his tank top. I love moments like that because we don't know what happened in there clearly something. Halstead shared that in addition to being tasked with creating a storyline that used the old Michael Scott Paper Company set, they also needed a storyline that they could cut away to. They needed somewhere to go. But that story also had to take place at Dunder Mifilin, because we did not have the budget to go anywhere. Right, and we only had four days. So this story of Phyllis throwing out her back and Dwight helping her was the solution.
他只穿着一件背心出来。我喜欢这样的时刻，因为我们不知道里面发生了什么，显然发生了一些事。霍尔斯特德分享说，除了被指派创造一个使用旧迈克·斯科特造纸公司布景的故事线之外，他们还需要一条可以切换过去的 storyline。他们需要一个去处。但这个故事也必须发生在邓德米夫林，因为我们没有预算去任何地方。对的，而且我们只有四天时间。所以菲利斯闪了腰、德怀特照顾她的这个故事就是解决方案。
And I love how scripts and stories sometimes evolve out of that just necessity. Everyone is concerned about Phyllis. There's like moaning sounds coming from the conference room. And Angela has a line to Michael where she says, Can you please go back to work instead of mastermining these situations wherein we hurt ourselves? this line was so hard for me to say. Why? Because I don't speak like that.
我喜欢剧本和故事有时是如何从这种纯粹的必要性中演变出来的。每个人都很关心菲利斯。会议室里传出类似呻吟的声音。安吉拉对迈克说了一句台词，她说，请你回去工作，而不是策划这些让我们自己受伤的情况好吗？这句台词我太难说出口了。为什么？因为我不那样说话。
I don't say stop mastermining situations wherein we hurt ourselves. Yeah. But Angela had a very formal way of speaking. She did. And it was something that was really important to the writers. They carry it through the whole entire series where she has sort of this clipped formality in her voice. I'm just pointing it out because I had a hard time saying it. To me, a sentence like that is very similar to being a doctor on like a show, but you're not really a doctor.
我不会说停止策划那些让我们自己受伤的情况。是的。但安吉拉有一种非常正式的说话方式。她确实有。这对编剧来说是非常重要的一点。他们在整部剧中都贯穿了这一点，她的声音有一种剪短的正式感。我只是指出来，因为我很难说出口。对我来说，这样的句子非常类似于在某个节目中扮演医生，但你并不是真正的医生。
doctor and you have to say medical jargon. I'd never make it. Gray's Anatomy, I'd never be able to do it. No, no, I can't do it. Can't do it. Well, somehow, Aaron and Kelly are going to wind up down in Cafe Disco. Aaron presses play on some music and the ladies start dancing. Yeah. Do you know what this song was? Was it boyfriend hangover? Yeah, it's called Boy Hangover. Boy Hangover. Do you know who wrote it? No. Our writer, Lester Lewis. You are kidding me. No.
医生，你必须说医学术语。我绝对不行。如果是《实习医生格蕾》，我绝对做不到。不，不，我做不到。做不到。好吧，不知怎么的，阿伦和凯利最后会来到咖啡迪斯科。阿伦按下某段音乐的播放键，女士们开始跳舞。是的。你知道这首歌是什么吗？是宿醉男友吗？是的，它叫《男孩宿醉》。男孩宿醉。你知道是谁写的吗？不知道。我们的编剧，莱斯特·刘易斯。你在开玩笑吧。没有。
I thought it was so catchy. It's sung by this woman named Bonnie McKee. She's a Grammy-nominated singer-songwriter. She has written number one hits for Britney Spears, Katie Perry, and Tau Cruz. I thought we should listen to it. Here's Boy Hangover. It is it that Lester wrote the lyrics to that song. It's so good.
我觉得这首歌太洗脑了。它是由一个叫邦尼·麦基的女人演唱的。她是一位获得格莱美提名的创作型歌手。她为布兰妮·斯皮尔斯、凯蒂·佩里和陶·克鲁斯写过冠军单曲。我觉得我们应该听一下。这就是《男孩宿醉》。就是莱斯特给这首歌写的歌词。太棒了。
I loved the song. I thought it was catchy. I downloaded it, and now I have it. have it. This was one of the songs I was listening to, you know, because I like to stay on theme while working on an episode. Yeah. Well, maybe we should take a break. I want to go eat my yogurt. It's been on my mind. Honey, I know it. If you are okay with that. I saw you eyeing your snack bag. I know. It's time. It's time. We'll be back after I eat my yogurt. Okay, we are back. My yogurt was great. Yay. And speaking of eating, Michael is eating his lunch alone.
我很喜欢这首歌。我觉得它很洗脑。我下载了它，现在我有了。有了。这是我听的歌之一，你知道的，因为我喜欢在创作一集时保持主题一致。好吧，也许我们该休息一下。我想去吃我的酸奶。我一直惦记着它。亲爱的，我知道。如果你不介意的话。我看到你盯着你的零食袋了。我知道。是时候了。是时候了。我们吃完酸奶就回来。好的，我们回来了。我的酸奶太好吃了。耶。说到吃，迈克正独自吃着午饭。
Might as well be dinner. That broke my heart. I know. So sad. Michael. Meanwhile, Phyllis is in the conference room. Dwight has started working on her back and Jim is outside collecting flowers. Yeah, it's very sweet. He's making a little bouquet for Pam. Jenna, this is on the side of the writer's building where the warehouse was. So automatically, I was like, is this 3.30 p.m.? Yes. Because we learned last week, we filmed there at 3.30. 30. Also, you know those flowers weren't there. No. They had planted them just for the scene so that he could then cut them. There have never been flowers there. Just some weeds, kind of. Yeah. And a giant bug. But that's it. Yeah. And then the big bunch of parrots that we had for a small period of time. And that one rooster across the way. But not flowers. But not flowers. So they would plant and then replant these flowers so that Jim could collect them. So those were some faky real flowers. Meanwhile, Cafe Disco is a poppin.
简直可以当成晚饭了。这让我心碎。我知道。太伤心了。迈克。与此同时，菲利斯在会议室里。德怀特开始帮她按摩背部，吉姆在外面收集花朵。是的，非常甜。他正在为帕姆做一个小花束。珍娜，这是在仓库所在的编剧大楼的那一侧。所以我自然而然地想，这是下午3点半吗？是的。因为我们上周了解到，我们在3点半在那里拍摄。还有，你知道那些花本来不在那儿。没有。那是为了这场戏特意种上的，以便他之后可以去剪。那儿从来没有过花。只有一些杂草，某种程度上。还有一只巨大的虫子。但仅此而已。还有我们曾经在很短一段时间内拥有的一大群鹦鹉。还有对面那只公鸡。但没有花。但是没有花。所以他们会种植然后重新种植这些花，以便吉姆可以收集它们。所以那些是一些假装是真实的花朵。与此同时，咖啡迪斯科正在火热进行中。
Aaron has invited a friend, Ashley. I loved the exchange between Oscar and Aaron when he's like, wait, you invited someone? And Aaron's like, yeah, is that not okay? And Oscar's like, I mean, I've worked here eight years and I never. And then they just run off and he goes rude. I just loved it. Ashley doesn't have any lines, but she was played by Alexis Teague.
阿伦邀请了一个朋友，阿什利。我很喜欢奥斯卡和阿伦之间的对话，当时他说，等等，你邀请了人？阿伦说，对啊，这有什么不可以吗？奥斯卡说，我是说，我在这里工作了八年，我从来没有。然后他们就跑开了，他说粗鲁。我太喜欢了。阿什利没有台词，但她由亚历克西斯·蒂格饰演。
And now begins what looks like a dance-off between Kelly and Andy. We had a fan question from Gianna W. The dance-off runner between Andy and Kelly is so great. I personally think they would have made a good couple. Did the writers ever think of doing that? So I asked Warren about this and he said the writer's room pretty much discussed every possible dating scenario for Kelly. But Andy and Kelly never made it on one of those note cards. And he said, you know what, that would have been great.
现在开始了看起来像是凯利和安迪之间的舞蹈比赛。我们收到了来自澳大利亚的吉安娜·W的粉丝提问。安迪和凯利之间的舞蹈插曲太棒了。我个人认为他们会是一对好情侣。编剧们有没有想过让他们那样做？所以我问了沃伦这件事，他说编剧室几乎讨论了凯利所有可能的约会场景。但安迪和凯利从来没有出现在那些便签卡上。他说，你知道吗，那会很棒。
I wish we would have gone there. I thought they had great chemistry. I did too. They seemed great for each other. And I would like you to note at 13 minutes 54 seconds at the beginning of the dance off, red chili pepper lights on the black pipe by the shower. Where did those come from? I don't know.
我希望我们当时能往那个方向发展。我觉得他们很有化学反应。我也这么觉得。他们看起来很适合彼此。我想请大家注意在13分54秒舞蹈比赛开始时，淋浴旁边黑管子上的红辣椒灯。那些是从哪里来的？我不知道。
Did Aaron and Kelly start decorating when they went down there? Did Ashley bring them? No. Oh, Ashley didn't bring them. Were they there? They were there. Oh, yeah, Ashley just got there. They weren't there when Phyllis was dancing, but now they're there for the dance off.
是阿伦和凯利下去时开始装饰的吗？是阿什利带来的吗？没有。哦，阿什利没带来。它们在那儿吗？它们在那儿。哦，对，阿什利刚到那儿。菲利斯跳舞时它们不在，但现在它们在舞蹈比赛时出现了。
And Michael is missing all of it. He's up in the kitchen being a sad sack. But he can hear it. He says, I can still hear the music in my head. Well, Creed is going to exit the bathroom. The men's room. While eating chicken. I really love that detail.
而迈克错过了这一切。他在厨房里当个失意鬼。但他能听到。他说，我依然能在脑海里听到音乐。好吧，克里德将从洗手间出来。男洗手间。一边吃着鸡肉。我真的很喜欢这个细节。
Halstead mentioned it was one of the little jokes that he loved as well. He's full on eating. eating a chicken leg. Yeah. Coming out of the restroom. And Creed's like, I hear it too, Michael. Creed says, I hear it too, boss. Oh, yeah.
霍尔斯特德提到这是他最喜欢的的小笑话之一。他正在大口吃着。吃着一个鸡腿。是的。从洗手间出来。克里德说，我也听到了，迈克。克里德说，我也听到了，老板。哦，对。
I hear it too, boss. So Michael's like, oh my gosh, something's happening. And sure enough, he gets down to the cafe disco and it's like happening. It's a party. There's a limbo pole. Yeah. And I have questions. Okay.
我也听到了，老板。所以迈克就像，哦天哪，有事情发生了。果不其然，他来到咖啡迪斯科，事情真的发生了。这是一个派对。有一根 limbo 杆（下腰杆）。是的。我有一些问题。好的。
Because it's so great. You see two people walk in and they have to like, you know, limbo under. Meredith does a shimmy. Your character walks in and just walks under it. Just straight under it. No problem. Didn't have to bend at all. Who wrote that joke?
因为太棒了。你看到两个人走进来，他们必须，你知道，在下面下腰。梅雷迪思扭动着走过去。你的角色走进来，直接从下面走过去了。直接走过去。毫无问题。根本不用弯腰。是谁写的这个笑话？
Well, I asked Warren and Halstead, and they both were like, it was Warren. Warren was like, yeah, that was me. Well, it's hilarious to me that this is my ex-husband's joke because he clearly knows I'm a short stack. Well, how did you do it? Did they bring you down and measure you to set the pole? Oh, yeah. They duct tape that pole. to the wall, right, that everyone walked under. It's like a broom. It's meant to look like a broom handle.
嗯，我问了沃伦和霍尔斯特德，他们都说，是沃伦。沃伦说，对，那是我。好吧，我觉得搞笑的是这是我前夫的笑话，因为他显然知道我个子矮。好吧，你是怎么做到的？他们把你带下去量尺寸来设置杆子吗？哦，是的。他们用强力胶带把那根杆子固定到墙上，对吧，每个人都从下面走过去。就像一根扫帚。它看起来像是一根扫帚柄。
Right. And I had to practice walking under it. I, on purpose this episode, I wear flats. My character never wears flats. My character is always in three inch heels. This entire episode, I had on little tiny flats. Wow. This is the shoe thing you were mentioning earlier. Yes, I'll put it in stories. I took a screen grab of them. And I did ever so slightly, guys, have to tilt my head, just very tiny. But I could walk right under that pole. It was so funny. I'm the person, guys, when your plane lands and everyone stands up and they're waiting and everyone has to duck because the overhead compartments, you know, when you're still at your seat, you haven't been able to get in the aisle because there's so many people getting their stuff. Yep. I can stand fully upright under the overhead.
对。我不得不练习从它下面走过。我这一集故意穿了平底鞋。我的角色从来不穿平底鞋。我的角色总是穿着三英寸的高跟鞋。这一整集我都穿着小小的平底鞋。哇。这就是你刚才提到的鞋子的事。是的，我要把它发到故事里。我截了它们的图。我确实稍微，伙计们，不得不把头倾斜一点点，就非常微小的一点点。但我可以直接从那根杆子底下走过去。太搞笑了。伙计们，我就是那种人，当你的飞机降落时，每个人都站起来等待，每个人都必须低头，因为头顶的行李舱，你知道的，当你还在座位上时，你还没办法走到过道里，因为有太多人在拿他们的东西。是的。我可以在头顶行李舱下方完全直立。
That must feel so good. Yeah. I just look at all these people, over while they're waiting to get off a plane, I got no problem. But don't ask you to get something off the top shelf. No. Why would I put anything on the top shelf? You don't. The only reason Angela is there is to get some signatures on a piece of paper, and Michael says he's only going to give her one signature per song. And Angela, you have this line where you say, I don't like the general spirit of music. My character says, look, I hate to be that person.
那感觉一定太好了吧。是的。我只是看着所有这些人，弯着腰在等下飞机，我完全没问题。但可别让我去拿顶层架子上的东西。不。我怎么会把任何东西放在顶层架子上？你不会的。安吉拉在那儿的唯一原因是在一张纸上得到一些签名，迈克说他每首歌只给她一个签名。安吉拉，你有这样一句台词，你说，我不喜欢音乐的总体精神。我的角色说，听着，我讨厌当那种人。
But I just don't like the general spirit of music. Renee from Fargo, North Dakota would like to know who wrote that line. She loves it. So we asked Warren and Halstead this question, and Warren said it's probably his favorite question because he loves that line too. He shared that he and Halstead were writing together on a short-lived show for the WB called Modern Men, starring Jane Seymour and Max Greenfield. And in one of the episodes, one of the guys is trying to break up with his drab girlfriend
但我就是不喜欢音乐的总体精神。来自北达科他州法戈的雷妮想知道是谁写的这句台词。她很喜欢。所以我们向沃伦和霍尔斯特德提出了这个问题，沃伦说这可能是他最喜欢的问题，因为他也喜欢那句台词。他分享说，他和霍尔斯特德曾一起为WB电视台一个名为《摩登男人》的短命节目编写剧本，该剧由简·西摩和马克斯·格林菲尔德主演。其中有一集里，其中一个家伙正试图跟他死板的女友分手
played by guest actor Arden Mirren. Oh, I love her. She's hilarious. She's so funny. Warren said she was amazingly funny. And Halstead and Warren had pitched a line that she hates music. And what Arden's character said was not a fan, like about music. And they said that Arden killed it and it was really funny.
由客串演员阿登·米伦饰演。哦，我爱死她了。她太搞笑了。她太有趣了。沃伦说她滑稽得惊人。霍尔斯特德和沃伦曾提出过一个台词，即她讨厌音乐。而阿登的角色所说的是“不是粉丝”，就像是关于音乐的。他们说阿登演得太棒了，真的很好笑。当他们去写这一集时，他们真的能看出安吉拉会对这一点感同身受。他们借用了自己的台词并做了一点调整。我觉得对一个人来说，这种性格特征太棒了，就是那种“我不懂音乐”。是的，我不是粉丝。我自己也不是一个狂热的音乐爱好者。珍娜，我知道你这一点，因为当我们去参加编剧休假时，你非常专注于我们的膳食计划。我们打算吃什么？我说了一些类似的话，车程的播放列表怎么样？
And when they went to write this episode, they really could see Angela identifying with that. and they borrowed their own line and added a little tweak. I think it is such an amazing character trait for a person to just be like, I don't get music. Yeah, I'm not a fan. I'm not a big music person myself. I know this about you, Jenna, because when we went on our writer's retreat, you were very concentrated on our meal plan. What were we going to be eating? And I said something like, what about a playlist for the car ride?
然后你说，好吧，我不在乎。我不知道是不是因为这个。但我开到洛杉矶的那辆车，没有空调，也没有能用的收音机。哦，天哪。你在长途旅行中开一辆没有音乐的车？是的，我在大学时也开过这辆车，我的大学离我的家乡有三个小时的车程。所以我经常在寂静中驾驶非常、非常、非常长的距离。珍娜。或者我有时会带一台老式的磁带播放机。
And you're like, yeah, I don't care. I don't know if this is why. but the car that I drove out to L.A., it had no air conditioning and no working radio. Oh, my gosh. You were driving in a car with no music on a road trip? Yeah, and I also had this car in college, and my college was three hours from my hometown. And so I would often drive very, very, very long distances in silence. Jenna. Or I sometimes did bring like an old-fashioned cassette player.
按播放键，我希望如此。是的，我可以从那播放。但我对无声驾驶变得非常适应。现在我听新闻或播客，但我从来没有真正迷上播放列表或音乐。我发现它，我不知道。我确实喜欢音乐。就像我有整张专辑。我有斯克兰顿之音。
And hit play, I hope. Yeah, I could play off of that. But I got really conditioned to driving without sound. And now I listen to news or podcasts, but I just never kind of got into playlists or music. I find it like, I don't know. I do like music. Like I have whole albums. I have sounds of scrans.
你知道的，比如我在构思一个角色时经常使用音乐，这太有趣了。因为如果你必须构思珍娜·费舍这个角色，你就不会有音乐。你除了好吃的之外没有任何音乐。是的，我的意思是，我很喜欢组合。我很喜欢公路旅行的播放列表。但随后我喜欢把它关掉然后聊天，你知道的，因为我很健谈。我妈妈总是说，最好的谈话地点是在车里。这就是为什么我喜欢接送孩子上下学。
You know, like I use music a lot when I'm formulating a character, which is so interesting. Because if you had to formulate the character of Jenna Fisher, you would have no music. You'd have no music but good food. Yeah, I mean, I love a combo. I love a love a playlist for a road trip. But then I like to turn it off and talk, you know, because I'm chatty. My mom always says the best place to talk is in the car. That's why I love to do school pickup and drop off.
我觉得我的孩子超级健谈。是的，谈论他们的一天。放学后立刻。是的。但我丈夫很喜欢播放列表，他为我们进行的每一次公路旅行制作播放列表。这真的很可爱，因为孩子们现在和它紧密相连。所以当我们去大熊山时，我们听了很多红辣椒乐队的歌。杰克会说，每当他们现在出现时，他就会说，那是大熊山。你知道，我的孩子们和李都对音乐有很深的联系，他们也做同样的事情。我们也有那些同样的事情。比如吸血鬼周末对我们来说就像2019年的夏天。那是吸血鬼周末。白色条纹乐队，《七国军队》。太棒了。当我们开车去圣达菲滑雪时，我们会听那首歌。哦，是的。所以每当我听到那首歌，我就会感受到雪山。
I feel like my kids are super chatty. Yeah, talking about their day. Right after school. Yeah. But my husband loves a playlist and he makes a playlist for every road trip we take. And it's really cute because the kids now are so connected to it. So we were listening a lot to the red hot chili peppers when we went up to the mountains in Big Bear. And Jack will say, whenever they come on now, he's like, that's Big Bear. You know, my kids and Lee are very connected to music and they do the same thing. And we have those same things. Well, like Vampire Weekend for us was like the summer of 2019. That's Vampire Weekend. White Stripes, Seven Nation Army. Love it. We would listen to that song as we were driving up to go skiing in Santa Fe. Oh, yeah. So whenever I hear that song, I just feel the snowy mountain.
我要去威奇托。是的。太棒了。太棒了。哦，我可以把我们带进有德怀特和菲利斯的会议室吗？他在那里把她当成牲口对待？他在把水獭油揉进她的背里。是的，还给她一根胡萝卜。
I'm going to Wichita. Yeah. It's so good. So good. Oh, can I take us into the conference room with Dwight and Phyllis? Where he's treating her like livestock? And he's rubbing otter oil into her back. Yeah, and giving her a carrot.
我原本以为这个水獭油的事情是编出来的。它是真的吗？女士，水獭腺体是可以买到的。哦，他们是怎么弄到的？嗯，从死水獭身上。好吧。他们取它们的肛腺。哦，天哪。
I thought for sure this otter oil thing was made up. Is it real? Lady, otter glands can be purchased. Oh, how do they get them? Well, from dead otters. Okay. They take their anal glands. Oh, Lord.
他们把它们磨碎，然后陈化，接着保存它们。谁想出来的？谁想出来的并说，保存那个水獭的屁股？我不知道。里面有些东西我需要把它们磨碎。你可以花大约八块钱买到一盎司。在另一个网站上，我看到你可以花六块钱买到。所以如果你在市场上，货比三家吧。人们用它来做什么？这正是我想要知道的。我想你是用它来诱捕水獭。你用它们自己的被磨碎的肛腺来诱捕水獭？
And they grind them up and they age them and then they preserve them. Who thought of that? Who thought of it was like, save that otter's ass? I don't know. There's some stuff in there I need to grind them. up. You can get one ounce for about eight bucks. On another website, I saw you could get it for six. So if you're in the market, shop around. What do people use it for? That's what I wanted to know. I guess you use it to lure an otter. You lure an otter with their own anal glands crushed up?
是的，用它们自己肛腺的气味。为什么？准确地说。我为什么要诱捕水獭？我猜。打猎，但这只是为了运动，因为你真的不用它们来做任何事情。你不用它们的皮毛，也不吃它们。你只是，我猜，洒上它们的肛腺然后杀死它们。为什么？这太可怕了。嗯，这种类似于……的市场很大。肯定有些我们不知道的事情。我不知道，但有很多腺体。为了诱捕的目的，你可以买到很多不同动物的腺体。所以基本上这些动物闻到它们自己的气味。我猜它们以为那是另一只水獭，然后它们出来打招呼。
Yeah, with the scent of their own anal glands. Why? Exactly. Why am I luring an otter? I guess. hunting, but it's just for sport because you don't really use them for anything. You don't use their fur or you don't eat them. You just, I guess, sprinkle their anal glands and then kill them. Why? This is horrible. Well, there's a whole market for this sort of like... Surely there's something we don't know. I don't know, but there's like a lot of gland. You can buy a lot of glands of different animals for this purpose of luring them. So basically these animals smell their own. And I guess they think it's another otter and they come out to say hi.
太可怕了。这对我来说简直就是重演《小鹿斑比》。我知道。而且没有关于把它揉进某人背部来治疗受伤的参考。我只想说，如果菲利斯去树林里，她会非常受欢迎。对她来说就像是一个白雪公主的时刻。会有很多水獭出来打招呼。好让德怀特和施鲁特家族杀了它们。
Terrible. This is like Bambi all over again for me. I know. And no references to rubbing it into someone's back for an injury. I just want to say if Phyllis went out to the woods, she would be very popular. It would like a snow white moment for her. She would have a lot of otters coming to say hi. So Dwight and the Shruths could kill them.
我想是吧。但这就是我找到的一些信息。我对所有这些信息感到困惑，但谢谢你分享它。不客气。好的。现在正在进行一场全面的舞蹈比赛。确实如此，我们收到了来自澳大利亚的亚历克西斯·W的邮件，她说，我必须知道安迪和凯利之间的舞蹈比赛是自由式的还是剧本写好的。
I guess so. But that is some information I found. I'm confused by all of that information, but thank you for sharing it. You're welcome. Okay. There is a full-on dance competition happening now. There sure is, and we got mail from Alexis W in Australia who said, I have to know if the dance competition between Andy and Kelly was freestyle or scrapery.
还是剧本写好的。女士，我去查了剧本。你猜怎么着？它是完全按照剧本演的。我要读给你们听这些描述。这是剧本中对安迪舞蹈比赛的描述。安迪拿了一把椅子，从它的椅背上跳过去，转过身，用弗雷德·阿斯泰尔式的步伐从它上面走过
or scripted. Lady, I went to the script. And guess what? It is fully scripted. I'm going to read you the descriptions. Here is Andy's dance-off description of the script. Andy takes a chair and hops over the back of it, turns around, does a fret astaire walk over it
以至于椅子的靠背倒在地上。他把它捡起来，坐在上面，以鲍勃·福斯的方式在上面旋转，闪现着爵士手势。然后他把一条腿跨过椅子的靠背，站起来，拿起椅子，假装椅子在攻击他，然后假装被椅子杀死。他站起来看着凯利，眼神仿佛在说，有本事超越这个。凯利的描述是这样的。凯利走向淋浴区。她假装打开淋浴，模仿自己淋湿并用肥皂起泡沫。
so that the chair's back falls to the ground. He picks it up, sits on it, and spins on it in a Bob Fossy fashion, flashing jazz hand. He then throws one leg over the back of the chair, gets up, picks up the chair, and pretends that the chair is attacking him and then pretends to be killed by the chair. He gets up and eyes Kelly like, try to top that. Kelly's description is this. Kelly walks over to the shower area. She pretends to turn on the shower and mimes getting wet and lathering herself with soap.
哦，天哪。然后她走到椅子旁，椅子就在安迪站立的地方旁边。她在椅子旁停下，像T台模特一样转身，向安迪眨眼，拿起椅子，带着它走回淋浴区。她坐下来，弓起背，跳舞状，假装被淋浴倾盆大雨淋湿。她在头周围狂乱地甩动头发。然后凯利开始跳起震感舞（crunk）。好吧，那是一个舞蹈动作。她把她最好的东西都拿出来了。
Oh, my. She then walks to the chair, which is next to where Andy stands. She stops at the chair, turns like a runway model, winks at Andy, picks up the chair, and walks back to the shower area with it. She sits down, arches her back, a la flash dance, and pretends to be drenched by the shower. She whips her hair around her head in a frenzy. Then Kelly starts crunking. Okay, that's a dance move. She's putting all her best stuff out there.
她确实拿出来了。嗯，你可能会注意到，它的描述方式并不完全是你最终在节目中看到的那个样子。那是因为兰迪确实雇了一位编舞。编舞的工作是诠释剧本，然后与演员合作设计他们的动作。兰迪说我们的编舞名叫玛丽·安·凯洛格。她是通过我们的第一副导演凯利·坎特利的推荐来到我们这里的。兰迪说她绝对超级棒，并且真正理解了这个场景。沃伦说他们必须用一个好的编舞，因为如果演员全程都在即兴发挥，剪辑将是不可能的。所以尽管明迪和爱德
She is. Well, you might notice that the way it is described is not exactly. how you end up seeing it in the show. And that is because Randy did hire a choreographer. And the choreographer's job was to interpret the script and then work with the actors to come up with their moves. Randy said our choreographer's name was Mary Ann Kellogg. And she came to us via recommendation from our first AD, Kelly Cantley. Randy said she was absolutely superb and really got this scene. And Warren said they had to use a good choreographer because if the actress had just freestyled the whole time, it would have been impossible to edit. So although Mindy and Ed
她是。嗯，你可能会注意到，其描述的方式与你在节目中最终看到的不完全一样。这是因为兰迪确实雇了一位编舞。编舞的工作是解读剧本，然后与演员合作设计他们的动作。兰迪说我们的编舞名叫玛丽·安·凯洛格。她是通过我们的第一副导演凯利·坎特利的推荐来到我们这里的。兰迪说她绝对一流，非常理解这场戏。沃伦说他们必须用一个好的编舞，因为如果女演员全程即兴发挥，剪辑将是不可能的。所以尽管明迪和埃德
brought a lot of ideas for what they would do, this was a planned out dance off. Yeah, sort of based loosely on the script, it seems, but it morphed. It evolved in this rehearsal process. And Halstead said he definitely remembers them pitching that flash dance moment. Mm-hmm. And that made it in. You know, something else that Randy shared with us was that we were not listening to music during this. They were using what's called a thump track. Again, for editing purposes, they would just have this speaker that would play like the sort of baseline beat of the song so that the actors would be on tempo. But for editing purposes, they put the song on later. I know.
提出了很多关于他们要怎么做的想法，这是一场经过精心策划的劲舞对决。是的，基本上是根据剧本来的，但它发生了变化。在这个排练过程中它演变了。霍尔斯特说他绝对记得他们提出了那个闪舞的时刻。嗯哼。而那也真的被收录进去了。你知道，兰迪跟我们分享的另一件事是，我们在这个过程中并没有听音乐。他们用的是一种叫做重低音轨的东西。同样，出于剪辑的目的，他们只会让这个扬声器播放类似歌曲的低音节拍，这样演员们就能踩准节奏。但为了剪辑，他们后来才把歌曲放进去。我知道。
So these guys are doing this whole thing. You were there. Was it so crazy? It was so crazy. And also, this is not about the dance off, but I could always really tell when there was no music when Ellie was dancing. Because Ellie just kind of does these jabs and kind of runs in place. Like, not at all to what the beat of the song was that's playing. But there was one little moment. In the background, I start to tidy up. Yes. And Michael tells Angela to stop. And this cracked me up, Jenna, because I do this in real life. I often at a party at a total strong. stranger's house. We'll start stacking plates, busing dirty cups, putting napkins in the trash bin, you know. Well, this is where we're similar because I do the same thing. Yeah. You know,
所以这些家伙在搞这么一出。你在场。是不是太疯狂了？太疯狂了。而且，这跟劲舞对决无关，但当埃莉跳舞时，我总是能真正看出当时没有音乐。因为埃莉只是做一些刺拳的动作，然后有点像在原地跑步。完全跟播放的歌曲节拍对不上。但有一个小片段。在背景里，我开始收拾整理。是的。而迈克尔叫安吉拉停下来。这把我逗乐了，珍娜，因为我在现实生活中也这样做。我经常在派对上，在一个完全不认识的陌生人家里。开始叠盘子、收脏杯子、把纸巾扔进垃圾桶，你知道的。好吧，这就是我们相似的地方，因为我也做同样的事。是的。你知道，
someone did that to me once. Like I had thrown a party and one of the moms went around and was like tidying kind of near the end. Yeah. And I was like, oh my gosh, that just took up like 25% of the cleaning. And it was such a nice gesture. So now I like to do it too. When I leave a party, I'll first do a sweep. Yes. And get rid of all the empty cans and glasses and stack the plastic cups. Yes. Put stuffed by the sink.
有人曾经对我这么做过。就像我办过一次派对，其中一位妈妈到处走，在快结束的时候帮忙收拾。是的。当时我就想，哦天哪，那直接帮我完成了大约25%的清洁工作。而且这是一个非常好的举动。所以现在我也喜欢这么做。当我离开一个派对时，我会先做一次清扫。是的。把所有空罐子和杯子清理掉，把塑料杯叠起来。是的。放在水槽旁。
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. I know. I related to Angela in that moment. But I love how she's like, am I not supposed to have any fun? Yes, because tidying is fun for her. We should probably check back in on Phyllis. Yeah.
嗯哼。嗯哼。我知道。那一刻我对安吉拉感同身受。但我喜欢她那种“难道我不能有一点乐趣吗”的反应。是的，因为收拾对她来说就是乐趣。我们大概应该去看看菲利斯了。是的。
Dwight is still trying to work out this kink in her back. And then Phyllis just blurts out. I think Bob's going to cheat on me with his new secretary. And then she starts laughing. And then her back is better. Yeah. And Dwight's like, why are you laughing? And she said, just saying it out loud, it just sounds so ridiculous.
德怀特还在试图缓解她背部的那个痉挛。然后菲利斯突然脱口而出。我觉得鲍勃要和他的新秘书出轨了。然后她开始笑。接着她的背就好了。是的。德怀特就问，你笑什么？她说，只要大声说出来，听起来就太荒谬了。
And she was able to let all that tension and stress go. We had a fan question from Liz Bee in Columbus, Ohio. She said, in this episode, Phyllis mentions that Bob might be having an affair, but then no one mentions it again. Was there more to this storyline that got deleted, either from this episode or future episodes? No, no, we asked Warren and Halstead about this, and they told us that their idea here was just that the cause of her back pain was the stress. And they thought it was a funny way to end this storyline of Dwight trying to heal her. Like, Dwight's treatments weren't the cure, and the dancing wasn't even the problem. Right.
而她能够释放所有的紧张和压力。我们有一个来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的莉兹·比的粉丝提问。她说，在这集里，菲利斯提到鲍勃可能有了外遇，但后来没有人再提起了。这个故事情节里是否还有更多被删减的部分，无论是来自这一集还是未来的剧集？不，不，我们问过沃伦和霍尔斯特关于这事，他们告诉我们，他们这里的想法只是她背痛的原因是压力。他们觉得这是结束德怀特试图治愈她的故事情节的一个有趣方式。就像，德怀特的治疗并不是解药，跳舞甚至都不是问题所在。对。
She was going to throw her back out anyway from just holding on to this little stress, and then she cured herself. And then Dwight had to staple her blouse back together. He did. So now we're about to see Jim and Pam. And Pam's going to come out of the bathroom. So cute. You looked so sweet, Jenna, and your pink dress and your hair up. I have to say something, though. What? Did you notice throughout the whole beginning of this episode that I had this pink dress on underneath my sweater? Well, it looked like a pink sweater with a pink skirt. So I thought it was a good faky sale. But then that tells me you wore the dress the whole day. Why? Yeah. Yeah. She went and did her hair all different and put flowers in her hair. Why couldn't she just bring her dress to work? I know. But also, why did she drive to New York to start art school in a pencil skirt? I don't know.
不管怎样，她只要一直背负着这点压力就会闪到腰，然后她自己治好了自己。接着德怀特不得不把她的衬衫重新钉在一起。他确实这么做了。所以现在我们要看到吉姆和帕姆了。帕姆要从洗手间出来了。太可爱了。你看起来太甜美了，珍娜，穿着粉红色的裙子，头发盘起来。不过我得说点什么。什么？你有没有注意到在这集的整个前半部分，我都穿着这条粉红色的裙子在毛衣里面？嗯，它看起来像一件粉红色的毛衣配一条粉红色的裙子。所以我以为这是一次很好的伪装。但这就告诉我你一整天都穿着这条裙子。为什么？是的。是的。她去把头发弄成各种发型，还在头发里插了花。为什么她就不能把裙子带到公司去呢？我知道。但话说回来，她为什么要穿着铅笔裙开车去纽约开始艺术学校的生活？我不知道。
Pam's a mystery when she comes to some of her wardrobe choices. She really is. She really, really is. I feel like people in the office would have clocked this strange, poofy bubble skirt coming out of her bottom half. I clocked it in the very first scene. Like, I was sitting in my chair. I was like, what is that? You know what I thought it was? I thought I had a blanket. Because you were cold. Yes. And I was like, oh my gosh, they caught my blanket.
帕姆在某些服装选择上真是一个谜。她真的是。她真的是，真的是。我觉得办公室里的人会注意到她下半身穿着这件奇怪的、蓬蓬的气球裙。我在第一场戏里就注意到了。当时我坐在椅子上。我在想，那是什么？你知道我以为那是什么吗？我以为我拿了一条毯子。因为你冷。是的。当时我就想，哦天哪，他们拍到我的毯子了。
And I was going to do a blanket catch. Proof of cold. I was like, oh, no, that's my wardrobe. Well, as they're walking out of the office, they hear the music playing and they're like, I think we should pop in. We should go just for a minute before we head to the courthouse. I think Jim says it would mean so much to him. Mm-hmm. Michael is thrilled. Oh, my gosh, she's so happy. The whole gang is there.
我还打算做一个拿毯子的动作。证明我很冷。我就想，哦不，那是我的服装。好吧，当他们走出办公室时，他们听到音乐在播放，然后他们说，我想我们应该去看看。我们应该在去法院之前去待上一分钟。我想吉姆说这对对他意义重大。嗯哼。迈克尔欣喜若狂。哦，天哪，她太开心了。全班人马都在那里。
And now everyone is dancing. I mean, except Angela. And Kevin and Lynn, who are making out. Full-on makeout, which is the end of the Kevin Bacon's runner. We got some mail about the dancing here. We're dancing to YMCA. Mm-hmm. Monica A and Jennifer P said,
现在每个人都在跳舞。我是说，除了安吉拉。还有正在热吻的凯文和琳。完全是法式热吻，这也是凯文·培根梗的结尾。我们收到了一些关于这里跳舞的邮件。我们在伴随着《YMCA》跳舞。嗯哼。莫妮卡·A和珍妮弗·P说，
were Jim's dorky dance moves choreographed, or is that John Krasinski's own true style? I don't think you're doing. dance moves were choreographed in the background. Sarah Lassen, 89, said, please address the fact that John Krasinski seems to only have one dance move jumping up and down. He does the same thing in the lip-dub cold open of nepotism. Oh my gosh. I will tell you, John and I met with the choreographer. Did you really? We did. Because we had this discussion, like, what is Jim and Pam's dancing going to be when they get there. And also they say they like cheesy. So what does that mean?
吉姆那些书呆子气的舞步是编排好的，还是约翰·克拉辛斯基自己的真实风格？我不认为你在背景里跳的舞步是排练过的。莎拉·拉森89说，请指出这样一个事实，约翰·克拉辛斯基似乎只有一个舞步——上下跳跃。他在《任人唯亲》的快闪冷开场里也做了同样的动作。哦，天哪。我得告诉你，约翰和我跟编舞见面了。真的吗？我们见过了。因为我们讨论过这个问题，比如吉姆和帕姆到了那里会跳什么舞。而且他们也说过他们喜欢俗气的。那是什么意思？
Well, we had all these conversations and one of them was, is there any reason why Jim and Pam might be slow dancing to YMCA where they're making kind of a wedding moment out of it? We discussed, we were like, I don't think so. I think we need to lean into the kind of like they like cheesy, you know. It's part of the reason they want a big wedding so they can be dorky with their friends on the dance floor. Yes. And so the choreographer just was like, well, let's see how you two would do it. I just remember, I feel like you could hear a pin drop. We're like, okay. I mean, that's really pretty much just us. That's just what I thought. Me and John just. I was shocked when you said you met with a choreographer. But they liked it. And so the choreographer was like, yeah, just do that. That's good.
好吧，我们进行了所有这些讨论，其中一个问题是，吉姆和帕姆有什么理由会伴随着《YMCA》跳慢舞，把这跳成一种婚礼时刻吗？我们讨论过，我们觉得不会。我们觉得我们需要倾向于那种他们喜欢俗气的风格，你知道的。这也是他们想要一场盛大婚礼的部分原因，这样他们就能在舞池里和朋友们一起表现得像个书呆子。是的。所以编舞就说，好吧，让我们看看你们两个会怎么做。我只记得，我觉得当时安静得连针掉在地上都能听见。我们就想，好吧。我的意思是，那真的差不多就是我们自己。那正是我所想的。我和约翰就。当你提到你和编舞见面时，我惊呆了。但他们很喜欢。所以编舞就说，好吧，就这么跳。这很好。
Perfect. That's good. Maybe she was like, I don't even know where to begin. So just do what you're doing. Well, I'll say I loved shooting these dance scenes. I was so happy to finally be down in the disco. But lady, I love a dance party. I know you do. And I will stay on the dance floor the whole time at your wedding. I want to be out on that dance floor. You know, for my 30th birthday, I had a dance party, and I danced the whole time.
完美。这很好。也许她当时想，我都不知道从何开始。那就按你们正在做的那样跳吧。好吧，我要说我很喜欢拍摄这些跳舞的场景。我太高兴终于能来到迪厅了。但是姑娘，我喜欢舞会。我知道你喜欢。而且在你婚礼上，我会一直在舞池里跳舞。我想去那个舞池。你知道，在我30岁生日的时候，我办了一个舞会，我跳了整整一晚。
And my 50th is going to be coming up in a few years, and I want a dance party again. You should have a dance party. And I maybe should put on the invitation. Wear comfy shoes. And I may not talk to you because I'm going to be dancing the whole time and that's what I want for my party. But for my 40th, I was seven months pregnant with my daughter. And so Lee and I just went and had a little baby moon slash birthday. So it'll be like 20 years since I had a dance party.
而且几年后我的50岁生日就要到了，我还想再办一次舞会。你应该办个舞会。我可能应该在请柬上写上：穿舒服的鞋子。而且我可能不会跟你说话，因为我要一直跳舞，这就是我对我生日派对的期望。但在我40岁的时候，我怀我的女儿已经七个月了。所以李和我只是去度了个微型满月假加生日。所以离我办舞会有大概20年了。
Well, I can't wait because I want me, you and Oscar. Oh! To recreate what we did for a year. years, which was we did all the single ladies by Beyonce, the three of us. I want all the single ladies. I want sexy back. I want gold digger. I want some lady Gaga.
好吧，我等不及了，因为我想让我、你和奥斯卡。哦！来重现我们当年做过的事，我们三个跳了碧昂丝的《Single Ladies》。我想要所有的单身女郎。我想要《Sexy Back》。我想要《Gold Digger》。我想要一些Lady Gaga。
Oh, yeah. I want them all. I just rewatched my wedding video because for my anniversary this year, my husband finally edited together all the footage from our wedding. Really? Yes. He said it took him a year because he just had to work on it a little bit at a time. It's almost 30 minutes.
哦，是的。我全都要。我刚刚重新看了我的婚礼录像，因为今年为了我们的纪念日，我丈夫终于把我们婚礼的所有素材剪辑到了一起。真的吗？是的。他说这花了他一年时间，因为他只能一点一点地处理。差不多有30分钟。
And we sat down with the kids and watched it. And it was so fun to see all of us dancing, Jenna. I mean, there were so many elements that were great. But it just warmed my heart. Like, there you are on the dance floor. We're like dancing our hearts out. It's just so great. Well, I want it.
我们和孩子们坐在一起看了。看我们所有人都在跳舞真是太有趣了，珍娜。我的意思是，有很多很棒的元素。但这真的温暖了我的心。就像，你就在舞池里。我们在纵情跳舞。这真的是太棒了。好吧，我想要这个。
You're going to have it. You're going to have a dance party. Okay, good. We painted hummingbirds for my 50th. And by God, we're going to dance on your 50th. Good. Yay. I'm going to make sure it happens.
你会拥有的。你会有一个舞会的。好吧，很好。我们在我的50岁生日上画了蜂鸟。上帝作证，我们要在你的50岁生日上跳舞。太好了。耶。我一定会让它实现的。
Well, there's one person who refuses to dance in Cafe Disco, and that is Angela. But, but she's going to sway her foot a little bit to the music. She's going to tap her finger. Yeah. And Hallstead shared that this whole storyline of Michael starting a Cafe Disco was always going to end with this moment. I did not know that. He said that their litmus test for whether or not Michael could pull. off his cafe disco dream was Angela because she thought that hanging out at a disco all day was
好吧，在迪斯科咖啡馆里有一个拒绝跳舞的人，那就是安吉拉。但是，但是她会随着音乐稍微晃动一下她的脚。她会用手指打节拍。是的。霍尔斯特分享说，迈克尔创办迪斯科咖啡馆的整个故事情节，最终注定要以这个时刻结束。我不知道这一点。他说他们用来检验迈克尔是否能实现他的迪斯科咖啡馆梦想的试金石就是安吉拉，因为她认为整天在迪斯科里闲逛是
completely unacceptable. She was the lone holdout through most of the show. And Michael, if you notice, keeps checking in with her, checking in with her, trying to engage her. So in the end, that little tap and that little foot sway, that is Michael's victory. That's his big win. And Warren shared, by the way, that in his mind, he thought that this moment actually is the beginning of an evolution for the character of Angela, that this moment that shows how severe and closed off her character can be, but it's a baby step toward her maybe opening up to new possibilities. Oh, I like that. So this moment was very rich in their outline and their writing of this episode. And very thought out. Well, I went to the script. I wanted to see what was in the
完全不可接受的。在整部剧的大部分时间里，她是唯一的坚守者。如果你注意的话，迈克尔一直在关注她，关注她，试图让她参与进来。所以最后，那个小小的拍打和那个小小的脚部晃动，就是迈克尔的胜利。那是他的巨大胜利。顺便说一句，沃伦分享说，在他看来，他认为这个时刻实际上是安吉拉这个角色演变的开始，这个时刻展现了她的角色曾经是多么严厉和封闭，但这迈出了一小步，也许让她对新的可能性敞开了心扉。哦，我喜欢这样。所以这个时刻在他们对这一集的构思和剧本创作中非常丰富。而且非常深思熟虑。好吧，我查阅了剧本。我想看看
shooting draft for this moment. There was a Michael voiceover. Here's what it says in the script. Michael sits with Angela. He looks around the room and takes in all of the dancing couples, Jim and Pam, Phyllis and Bob, Kelly and Andy, and Kevin and Lynn, who are furiously making out. Michael notices Angela is tapping her foot to the music and he smiles to himself. And this is the voiceover that would then play. They needed me. I left. I will never let them down again. I will always be there for them. I will be at every important moment of their lives. Their births, their deaths, their babies, other hospital stuff, no matter where or whether they want me there or not for them. That actually made me get a little choked up. I know, isn't that so
这个时刻的拍摄初稿里有什么。有一个迈克尔的画外音。剧本里是这样写的：迈克尔和安吉拉坐在一起。他环顾房间，将所有跳舞的夫妻尽收眼底，吉姆和帕姆、菲利斯和鲍勃、凯莉和安迪，还有正在疯狂热吻的凯文和琳。迈克尔注意到安吉拉正随着音乐用脚打拍子，他暗自微笑。接下来播放的就是这段画外音。他们需要我。我离开了。我再也不会让他们失望了。我会一直在他们身边。我会在他们生命中的每一个重要时刻出现。他们的出生、他们的死亡、他们的宝宝，以及其他医院的事情，不管他们是在哪里，不管他们是否希望我在那里陪着他们。这真的让我有点哽咽。我知道，这不是超级
sweet? I really wish that had been in. I know. I thought that was really sweet. One other thing I want to share is that when we were filming in cafe disco and trying to figure out this moment of how Michael would see my foot swaying, my finger tapping, we shot just a quick little tag that didn't make it in. And everyone has left cafe disco and only Angela Martin is in their cleaning. And Michael walks by and she is dancing as she cleans. Why do I remember this? We just shot it really quickly. And just as an alt, just in case. Yeah. Like, you actually respond to the music when everybody's left.
甜吗？我真的希望那段被收录进去。我知道。我觉得那真的很甜。我想分享的另一件事是，当我们正在迪斯科咖啡馆拍摄，并试图弄清楚迈克尔如何看到我的脚在晃动、手指在打节拍的这个时刻时，我们拍了一个没有被最终采用的小彩蛋。每个人都离开了迪斯科咖啡馆，只有安吉拉·马丁在里面打扫卫生。迈克尔走过，她边打扫边跳舞。为什么我记得这个？我们拍得非常快。我们只是当时随手拍的。当然，作为一个备选方案，以防万一。是的。就像，当所有人都离开时，你实际上对音乐有了反应。
Everyone's left. But it's still that victory. He still got you. Yeah. But that didn't make it in. It's not in the shooting draft. It's not in deleted scenes. But that was an alt that they shot.
所有人都离开了。但那仍然是胜利。他依然拿你没办法。是的。但那没有被收录进去。拍摄初稿里没有。被删减片段里也没有。但那是他们拍的一个备选方案。
I wonder if we were all like waiting in the hallway while you did that or something because I have such a memory of it. It was really quick. We just sort of grabbed it in the moment. But of course, the actual tag that made it in, which is so great, is Kelly piercing Andy's ear in the restroom. This really lends itself to that idea that they could be a couple. I know. Because this is a very cute, coupling thing. It is. And Halstead said that they actually did a take where Mindy, as Kelly, fully pierces Andy's ear, and it was painful and bloody
我在想，当我们做那个的时候，是不是所有人都一直在走廊里等着，因为我对它太有记忆了。非常快。我们只是在当时顺手抓拍了一下。但当然，最终被收录进正片并且非常棒的彩蛋，是凯莉在洗手间里给安吉拉打耳洞。这真的印证了他们可能会成为一对的想法。我知道。因为这是一个非常可爱的情侣做的事。确实是。霍尔斯特说，他们其实拍过一个版本，明迪饰演的凯莉真的给安吉拉扎了耳洞，而且又疼又流血
and a mess, but they cut it for time. Well, that's it, guys. That's Cafe Disco. It is, and it was so fun. I loved rewatching this. Thank you so much. Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan, Randy Cordray, for giving us all kinds of fun behind the scenes details. And lady, before we go, you know how at the beginning of the episodes, we always say, like, when do you listen? Where do you listen? You always say good morning and then you remember that people might not listen in the morning.
一团糟，但为了时长被剪掉了。好吧，就是这样，各位。这就是迪斯科咖啡馆。是的，太有趣了。我喜欢重温这一集。非常感谢。沃伦·利伯斯坦和霍尔斯特·萨利文、兰迪·科德雷，为我们提供了各种有趣的幕后细节。还有，姑娘，在我们离开之前，你知道在每一集的开头，我们总是会说，你们什么时候听？你们在哪里听？你总是说早安，然后你才想起来人们可能不是在早上听。
Yes. Well, we got a letter from Katie C., who is 14 years old, lives in the UK, and she said, I listen to office ladies whilst delivering newspapers every day, and it makes it so much more fun. When it's raining or way too warm for my ginger jeans, I know I have the podcast to keep me going and I never give up. I love that. Well, hi, Katie. Hi, Katie. Good luck today on your paper route. Be safe. And Jen and I are sending you big hugs. Thanks for listening to Office Ladies. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced
是的。好吧，我们收到了一封来自凯蒂·C的信，她14岁，住在英国，她说，我每天在送报纸的时候听《办公室淑女》，这让工作变得有趣多了。当外面下雨或者对于我的姜黄色牛仔裤来说太热时，我知道我有这个播客陪伴我，我绝不放弃。我太喜欢了。好吧，嗨，凯蒂。嗨，凯蒂。祝你今天的送报路线一切顺利。注意安全。我和珍娜给你一个大大的拥抱。谢谢你收听《办公室淑女》。谢谢你收听《办公室淑女》第二杯。本集最初与Earwolf合作创作。《办公室淑女》是Audyssey的一个节目，由
by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”节目由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Audyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本节目由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。